Vladimir Putin he uh did a partial
mobile he declared a partial
mobilization in Russia 300 000 troops
calling in reservists he said we're not
going to conscript people just yet we're
just bringing in the reservists but he
did threaten to use nuclear weapons in
Ukraine and some people are saying it's
like a threat against the West I guess
because NATO is basically backing
Ukraine as it is but a retired General
said that if he does the U.S will
probably or could hit Crimea and strike
the Black Sea Fleet so I don't know
world war three maybe maybe it's all
Bluster I don't know I don't think Putin
is going to back away from this fight I
don't think anyone is going to back away
the U.S won't let Russia take these you
got four regions now saying they're
going to vote to join Russia so
everybody started losing their minds and
uh I don't know maybe World War III
already started at least the pope thinks
so yeah another story we got this one's
really funny Karine Jean-Pierre is
walking back Biden's statements about
the pandemic being over I'm just
wondering okay well does he have any
Authority or autonomy as the president
at this point because clearly he doesn't
so we'll talk about that plus uh Bill
Maher he's got another one he came out
and he said the Democrats need to drop
the wokeness and stop talking about
pregnant men and this one's just so so
good because I seem to recall when
Dennis Prager went on his show and said
that they're claiming men can have
periods and Bill Maher was like no
they're not blah blah now here's Bill
Maher going maybe they should stop
talking about that talk about turning it
all around
it's amazing how times have changed
we'll get into all this and much much
more we have this other big story that
guy who killed that teenager in North
Dakota he is free on bail so a lot of
people are really pissed because they
think he should have been remanded this
is a violent politically motivated
attack this was over terrorism and the
guy's out the guy's free on bail so
that's kind of crazy before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member in order to
support our work and tonight we are
going to have a members only after show
last night was really really fun we
played a game called Mary F indict
indict yeah we don't want to say gallery
on that indict indict so who would you
marry who would you bang and who would
you indict there you go still it was not
family friendly at all Luke's had some
crass things it was fun you'll want to
watch tonight over at timcast.com we're
gonna have that uncensored show it's
gonna be great you'll also get other
shows like cast Castle Vlog and tells me
the inverted world so don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
Channel and my friends
many of you have pointed out you're not
getting notifications for the show
anymore and this is true and correct
we've heard it for many many people that
even if you click the notification Bell
it's not happening so you must be the
notifications that you want to see from
YouTube If you are concerned about that
then take the URL post it wherever you
can and notify people because YouTube
isn't doing it and I think the reason is
is obvious it's censorship we've got a
ton of stories coming out about the
federal government colluding with big
Tech like Twitter and Facebook you think
that's not happening with YouTube it
probably is and they're probably going
there and saying hey don't let these
guys talk about this stuff and then they
do stuff like remove notifications so
smash that like button share the show
with your friends joining us today to
talk about this and so much more
especially culture it's Rick and Trey
from Adelitas Way so happy to be here
well yeah grab your mic bro what's up
I'm Trey Stafford drummer Adelitas Way
and I'm just so happy to be here with
all these amazing people in this room
right on man so uh who are you guys
we're a rock band
um well I'd say we're even journalists
at this point we just make music that we
feel that motivates people uplifts
people whether that's in accomplishing
your goals finding love I feel like our
music has a very positive message and I
think that it's very important for us to
use the platform that we've we've built
to bring people together and to
encourage uh communities and and
especially the Rock Community to stick
together and look after each other so
that's a very important part of of why
we're in a band and call out the weird
corporate wokeness and garbage in the
industry I'd imagine oh yeah I mean
we've been battling against that for for
over a decade now and sometimes we tell
the stories of our journey and again
people don't believe it people won't
believe when you tell them the truth
I'll give people a quick little taste
because we'll get into this later but
you guys were mentioning how like your
managers would call you up and be like
post these like activist messages or
something like that right they would
just kind of schedule your posts were
going to look like what your day was
going to look like and if you you know
oh at 10 A.M you're gonna post this or
and then at one you're gonna post this
and it's going to be supporting this and
it's always like some form of agenda
right but I think one of the reasons we
didn't fit into the system was because I
was I guess labeled a difficult person
to handle because I would say what I
wanted or I would I would have put my
own opinion on it and and I'd have an
email from nine people who'd be like you
need to take this down or like you're
just always I felt like I was always
getting yelled at right I feel like no
one wants to they're like oh what's it
like being a rock star get yelled at all
the time but this is why so many people
in the Arts won't speak out even though
it's like that Meme where the guy's
burning the woman he goes I agree with
everything you say because there's all
these people around them saying don't
you do it don't you step out of line
because if you do they punt you out oh
you get punted out and it's even beyond
that they point you out and then they
try to throw stones at you the whole way
we as you try to you know get going
again right it's it's a real Blacklist
thing you know I've had people go
against us that have spent more time
trying to make sure we didn't make it as
an independent band than they did trying
to help us when they were on our team
because a very weird situation because
it's a cult but we'll get we'll get more
into that later too because this is it's
really crazy hearing these stories we
were hanging out the Blue Ridge Rock
Fest and we were you were talking to me
and all about this we're like we got to
talk about it more so we'll get into it
thanks for for joining us dudes we just
got lukakowski super excited to talk
about the satanic influence over the
music industry just a little bit nothing
crazy you know just the reality of our
current situation my name is Lou
kardowski of we are change.org we talked
about the shirt that I'm wearing
yesterday I thought I would just wear it
it says if I told you so it was a person
and it has a nice picture of Dr Ron Paul
on there you could get it on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do I'm here thank you so much for having
me we have a workout room and I was like
I'm showing Rick earlier I'm like so
here's the kitchen like here's the
workout room there's a picture of Ron
Paul in the door for some reason and
there's a life-size cut out of Ron Paul
standing next to it I don't know why
inspiration we're fans around Paul I
guess on the drive to Vegas to
California there's a big Ron Paul
Revolution billboard and I I honor it
every time we drive by it that's awesome
salute it you're like yes yes we gotta
Ian chilling I've been thinking a lot
about ordering chaos maybe we'll go
deeper on this because I'm starting to
read uh the covid-19 the great reset
Cloud Schwab book and thinking about how
they really want to establish a world
order out of what they believe is cast
but I think there's a lot of value to
chaos as well I think you need to
balance of both you dudes like we uh I
don't know if anyone knows but you guys
we met up at Blue Ridge Rockfest like
you were saying Tim and uh got to watch
Trev just slanted oh man even before the
show when you were getting pumped you
were pumping me up just just
it sounded like you were like pouring
water on the table it was so smooth like
percolating that Rhythm man marching
band that four years of high school
marching band just uh those rudiments
man they they get they get you good do
you do that before a show usually just
drum and get in the zone or something
every show a little bit of yoga a little
bit of stretching and uh you know after
doing this for 15 years and having all
the travel like you got to make sure
your body's in really good shape to put
on the performance that you want to put
on yeah when you're sticking the air as
you're playing with one hand and then
catching yeah that was awesome I was
like I hope he doesn't drop it I hope my
thoughts aren't going to interrupt his
thoughts ah Collective Consciousness
what yeah that's how I think Tim all
right
glimpse into Ian's mind thank you guys
for joining us I loved adelita's way
when I was in high school and I'm stoked
that you guys are here I gotta get a
picture with you for sure I wasn't able
to go to the Festival what was that just
a couple years ago yeah
I just got it not too long ago you know
what's up but I'm stuck let's get going
let's get into this uh end of the world
business yeah okay the first story we
got from the New York Post is uh the New
York Post reports the apocalypse is nigh
the end is here buy your emergency food
I'm just kidding I didn't say that it
says not a bluff Putin mobilizes
reservist threatens West with nuclear
weapons nuclear weapons
quote when the territorial Integrity of
our country has threatened to protect
Russia and our people we will certainly
use all the means at our disposal it's
not a bluff
Putin accused the west of engaging in
nuclear blackmail and noted statements
of some high-ranking representatives of
the leading NATO States about the
possibility of using nuclear weapons of
mass destruction against Russia he
denied he did not identify who made such
comments so here's the thing they're
pulling in 300 000 reservists they were
already using these these a crazy
incendiary devices all over Ukraine
here's the Big Challenge I don't believe
any of it from anybody you can it can be
the Moscow times it can be Vladimir
Putin himself it can be Joe Biden
himself it can be the New York Times and
I'm gonna be like I don't believe any of
you the U.S has its interests they're
not going to tell us that right truth
because it would make them look bad
Russia same thing everybody's trying to
propagandize so who knows well the only
thing I can't say is Putin gave this
speech so you can like see him talking I
guess some people think it's a deep fake
but look you know I think Vladimir Putin
absolutely would use low-yield nuclear
weapons on Ukraine to win this war at
the very least he's going to say he
would you have to as a president say we
will use every every possible option
nothing is off the table that's a very
popular phrase you're talking about the
end of the world Ian again we saw and I
agree with you Tim a lot of this is
posturing a lot of this is saber
rattling a lot of this is trying to
Galvanize uh you know his country and
his people to go along with what he
believes in we see the United States do
the same thing we can't believe anyone
here but we saw Vladimir Putin kind of
allude to this now he's directly saying
it and he's also doing it in a way which
I think is laying down the groundwork
for a potential strategy which is going
to be dangerous for everyone because the
Ukrainian territories are going to be
going under a specific election to join
Russia very soon which will officially
probably make them Russian territories
now if there's Russian territories that
were former Ukrainian territories when
the ukrainians attacked this Vladimir
Putin is laying down the groundwork
saying specifically I could just nuke
them because they attacked Russian
territory so this is the groundwork that
they're setting up here this is an
extremely dangerous situation and it
could have been all avoided foreign
affairs wrote an article saying
specifically that in April of this year
Russia and Ukraine negotiated a peace
deal they were about to sign a peace
deal they tentatively agreed to it and
then Boris Johnson flew to Ukraine and
said no don't do it this war could have
been stopped it could have been
prevented it wasn't it's only escalating
from here and it's endangering everybody
it may be the end of the world
but not like I don't think Putin's gonna
launch a 50 Megaton bomb ICBM at London
or something no we were talking about
small strategic nuclear weapons but the
US would retaliate absolutely other
other countries most likely well it's
hard to tell it's hard to say exactly
because we don't know the full scale we
don't know the latest technology out
there when we think of nuclear weapons
we're thinking of Hiroshima and Nagasaki
but we're thinking incorrectly because
this is technology that is almost 100
years old and is absolutely nothing
compared to the latest technological
advancements that the Russian military
has the Chinese military has in the US
military has we're talking about weapons
that could end at the planet 10 times
over easily now and that's what we know
about imagine what we don't know about
so there's still a lot of mystery here
we don't know what's going on we see one
side of the story being purported a lot
of it is pro-war there should be another
side to it saying hey stop with this
Insanity these politicians shouldn't be
sending people to die for their causes
and their influences this is stupid all
around what is the cause anyway what's
the point War Yeah just they want to
connect the land between Crimea and
Russia they want that eastern Ukraine
it's far more complicated and a lot of
it is energy also included but but
that's just I'll I'll keep it simple for
the sake of contemporary politics Russia
has one warm water Port Crimea if
Ukraine goes NATO they lose access to
the Black Sea and shipping oil and other
resources they can get there from the
East I was looking at a map but it's a
bridge and I haven't one Bridge into
your territory is not secure so they
want they want multiple highways there's
two big highways that go in through
Ukraine that they probably want access
to they need access to the Black Sea
they have a fleet there they need it and
then they're going to be holding the
turkey you understand turkey has the
Bosphorus yeah the boss for a straight
is Turkish so if the Russians turkey and
Greece is part of NATO at odds with each
other and there's also a big flash point
there that may lead to a war between uh
Greece and Turkey and there's also a lot
of oil and energy found specifically in
that region that Russia is now occupying
that could make Ukraine a petrol state
if Ukraine is a petrol State and is with
the European Union it's game over for
Russia and they know know this all right
it's all it's all extremely esoteric
let's wait let's bring it back home to
Earth you guys are rock stars so you
know the the when are you guys playing
in Moscow yeah
you know this stuff's like this is
really in the weed stuff but I'm
wondering if it's this kind of thing is
breaching into your world concerns about
global recessions economic collapse war
Civil War or whatever oh it it all
affects us I feel like musicians are the
ones that get affected by everything
right it's right away we noticed
um a recession is right now A lot of
people are still trying to figure out
you know I guess officially because no
one will admit it but we're in a
recession we can tell when we're on the
road right when you're when gas prices
are six hours a gallon when hotels have
doubled in cost like people don't want
to travel anymore you get less people
con you know going to concerts when
you're on stage and the panties being
thrown at you are from Walmart yeah
right right instead of Victoria's Secret
they don't come because they'll tell you
about it we were going to throw our
paintings on stage but we just couldn't
yeah we met people on the last couple
runs we've done that have three jobs and
and can't afford the rent so it's it's a
very weird time and and to to see us
constantly throwing as much money as we
are at War right you know how many
billions are we given towards this world
on the books yeah right and and there's
more common and we did this already once
in Afghanistan we've already we've
already you know given so much money
towards War right our biggest fear for
the last couple years was oh we don't
want to go to war we don't go to war
well here we are we're right into a war
right now we're feeding money into this
war why people here in the United States
can't pay the rent there there's uh
places don't have clean water in the U.S
there's there's all this stuff going on
here but but we continue to ignore that
and and focus on this war like it's like
it's a good thing no no I hear you know
the Arts are overrun with like leftists
and liberals y'all didn't vote for Biden
did you we did not you know and and at
the end of the day
um
I feel like I I knew what was going to
happen that's happening right now I felt
like that came with with that vote in
you know I feel like when when yeah I
feel like when if we were to vote for
Biden it would be to
vote for what we're talking about like
almost a recession you know an increase
in energy we we knew when he came in the
gas was going to go to six dollars a
gallon we knew hotels were going to
double we knew so so for us you know
we're seeing our whole lives change and
then not not to to Discount the fact
that in 2020 we were the industry that
they pretty much told your shutdown
you're not playing any concerts you know
the the only article we ever got written
in Rolling Stone about us was that you
know we had number one hits we sold
hundreds of thousands of Records Rolling
Stone ignored us our entire career we
played one outdoor Festival in late 2020
and they called us murders they were
like adelita's ways currently killing
people as they play a concert outside
it's like you know to
to use the media to try to do that to a
band that's been working for 15 years to
write the first story about us to be a
negative one about how we wanted to give
people entertainment during a really
tough time which we continue to do right
we we went on tour with Skillet we were
doing live streams for our fans playing
live concerts for them when everyone was
locked in their houses like we care
about our fans and and we wake up
thinking every day you know how can we
how can we make them you know feel like
they're with us now how can we make them
feel like we're thinking of them so we
put on these live streams we played
these concerts and we got crucified in
in the record industry
creepy but if you if you come out and
you put on your pink little hat we have
a Ukrainian flag and and Advocate and
vote towards giving billions of dollars
to the war effort you're good they put
you on front State they put you as as
the main act with all these big
celebrities this big Ukraine benefit and
they'd be like you're so brave and and
Noble doing this it seems like that a
lot of people in Industry just in
general are obsessed with germ theory of
disease and they don't focus enough on
terrain they theory of disease these
yeah and when they're wrong they don't
never come out and say anything about
the wrong information they were given
right that that's the problem that I had
the problem that I have is if you're
going to force someone into a way and
then and then you're not right about
that way after facts come in you you
should say sorry sorry about that guys
or or like you know don't try to rule
with such an iron fist over people the
way that these paths these past couple
years I've been iron fisty you know you
guys played in late 2020 you played
throughout 2021 I'd imagine you know
you're playing now how how would you how
would you uh like describe your fans do
they tend to be people who are like this
is this is busted this is this is BS
you're doing a good thing or do you get
people who are wearing masks being like
why aren't you wearing a mask well we've
had it both ways we've had we've had
people stop following us because that
type of thing going on but we've also
had people come around and say look you
know
um I felt this way but then after
learning and doing my own research and
learning more about this you know I was
kind of mad at you guys at this point
but now that I'm here and I've learned
more you know I understand because what
we're trying to do is provide
entertainment for for our fans and also
feed our family not become one of the
stories that we're hearing so many of
right now like people are getting
evicted from their homes people are
living in tents we travel all across the
world and we travel all across the
United States and when you're in some of
these Progressive States
um I can name a list of them you're
you're people will not believe you're
playing out you see the agenda playing
out you see thousands of tents thousands
of homeless people thousands of people
waiting for just a truck to come by to
give them water you know when we played
Portland over the winter
there were there were thousands of tents
in the streets and there were ambulances
coming and picking up people who had
frozen to death the night before
Portland in Portland it's not even that
cold right but they're older people
right you you if you're cold and you're
older and you don't got the means to to
survive right your immune systems are
lower people were dying and they'll just
come pick them up in the ambulance drive
them off and you don't hear anything
about this and we we I think what helps
us have the the head on us that we have
is we meet so many of our fans we hear
so many of these stories we hear stories
about people working three jobs getting
evicted we hear stories about people
working 50-hour weeks and they can't
afford uh anything extra right like we
have fans that that have been the 20 30
shows of ours that write us emails like
I'm so sorry that I'm not going to make
it when you come to Houston because I
can't afford to drive the normal three
hours like I would gas is seven dollars
six dollars a gallon rent is this you
know it's it's really effect in the
music industry and for some reason our
peers in the music industry we continue
to support this type of of uh you know
attack on gas that's our our careers
there's no there's no electric vehicle
that we could drive across the country
right now in Turin right yeah doesn't
exist technology is not there yet do
people ever wear masks when they perform
I want to see hold on did you guys see
what band was it uh what band was it the
Clean Hands guys oh yeah yeah oh yeah
who was that yeah they were like
everybody has Clean Hands and they're
all like yeah yeah it's all dude no oh I
know these I know the name you know the
name it's the uh I predictor Riot you
know that band yeah
look what they're singing about well
yeah we gotta exiled man they found out
we love Liberties
is that who it was everybody wash your
hands they were like
Yeah The Crowd Goes Wild and they're
like all in this cult weird like I was
like brothers
being in a band does it feel like a cult
like you're the cult leaders and it's a
cult like the fans now I have your
Kaiser Chiefs maybe I don't know about
these guys like I wonder about the fan
artist relationship because I'm an
artist too and I'm real concerned like I
don't want to you know I want people to
think for themselves and to be
independent human beings but I also want
people to come watch me perform when I
perform we know like half of our fans by
name and we have a lot of them and we
and and he takes the time to meet as
many fans after every single show and we
we connect with our fans and we make
that's our number one priority is
connection with our fans is the only
reason we're where we are today as an
independent band because everybody in
the corporate music Industries tried to
crush us since we became independent so
we we have to we have to be with our
fans stop assault definitely well check
this out so we were shouting out Tom
McDonald you guys know Tom right yep
he's number three billboard digital
sales with his new song Riot I looked on
the other charts I couldn't find them
maybe I just don't know where the charts
are but I look at hip-hop and rap he's
not there and I'm like something is BS
there's no way dude got millions of hits
when he dropped that music video and
he's number three in digital sales I
don't trust the industry at all no
they'll do whatever it takes it's a cult
and they want to control the Arts to
control the narrative and manipulate
people but more importantly they want to
make sure you guys stay in line they
want you so we were talking about the
show uh earlier in the show about a
particular band I don't want to say the
band I don't like dragging other
people's right into things but a big
band and all of a sudden they're like
posting things about abortion and stuff
like that and I'm like I think they're
woke and then you guys were saying nah
they probably have managers who told
them they have to post it yeah because
you get you get blacklisted like if you
don't comply you start noticing your
opportunities going down right but the
what Trevor was saying it doesn't matter
when you have amazing fans when you have
amazing fans they lose their power the
media the media was more powerful I
think they're becoming less trustworthy
overall and and over the past couple
years because people are kind of like
being a they're aware more now than ever
of what we're being fed constantly is
not the truth so so I think the media is
losing its luster a little bit and I
think that the music industry is just
another Avenue that the media uses to to
brainwash people or control people or
that's a whole other can of worms but
they're using their biggest artists to
try to yeah it's like a battle of the
Cults you know I mean no matter what
we're all in Cults if some sort of way
beat your family maybe it's your friend
group that's Community
okay call this to be like think for
yourself don't look at me but hold on to
go back to the the topic that we were
just discussing here to segue this
conversation music and performers were
always kind of known as being anti-war
what do you guys think happened to this
anti-war element the first thing that
comes to mind is this famous thing by
Tupac they got money for Wars but can't
feed the poor we don't see that those
kind of lyrics we don't see this kind of
galvanizing anti-war push
anti-establishment push from the music
industry like we used to what happened
these artists are selling their soul
it's not it's not pure
passion anymore it's more just about the
money The Bling
whatever whatever their shortcomings are
like whatever the the the their they
want you know in the in the short term
instead of thinking about a long-term
passion long-term goal so whatever they
got to do to to come up that and like so
quick
you know they're they're just gonna
follow whatever orders they got I think
what we're seeing right now is that
they're all the way there's always been
a contingent of people with no morals no
principles they just want they want
stuff they want money they want power
and they want social acceptance yeah and
what's happening is because the internet
you can you can see it's it's being
filtered out and so those people they're
they're they're the ones who are going
on Twitter and they're like you know in
big bands or whatever and they have the
Ukrainian flag and they're just saying
like yeah War sure whatever you say
because like I was just saying if you
guys you know go to a festival or you
get you get a manager whatever and
you'll be like yeah tell them we want to
do a festival benefiting Ukraine oh then
all of a sudden they're going to be like
we'd like to get the Rolling Stone there
we'd like to get New York Times there
they're going to do a profile on you
they're going to give you this big you
know multi-page spread in magazines or
websites I guess people don't buy
magazines anymore and then they're like
we're gonna sign a deal with you and
give you everything you want if you've
supported the war machine I think it's
also the lack of Education in the
schooling system for the younger
generation I think a lot of these people
don't even know what anti-war means like
and I want to make a distinction here
because you could still support Ukraine
and still be anti-war there still is a
human cost to this war that's affecting
everyone that gets lost and you know the
humanity is being lost here because all
we're seeing is pro war Pro you know
said more weapons said more murder
except you know we should we should be
hearing we should be having those
conversations saying let's try to stop
the murder maybe and and and and music
used to be that vessel used to be that
voice that used to break through the the
news break through the conditioning and
inspire people to stand up for peace and
I think it got taken out by radicals in
a sense I do I think the music industry
has been overtaken by by radical
ideology from the top the leaders of it
because if if you were to make a song
like that right now like what you're
saying you you would be you would I
think you could end up dead as an artist
I think you would I think you'd if you
wrote a song that that kind of went that
against the Green like you know people
are starving you know I gotta I'll push
back I think maybe a few years ago but
we're seeing people doing it yeah they
are now like a lot of I mean well I mean
Tom McDonald the obvious one but um the
Dixie Chicks called out the bush
invasion of the war in Iraq why didn't
they walk that back and then they
dropped Dixie from their names or
whatever yeah or whatever and then you
had um the uh Lady Antebellum I think
they like changed their name to Lady Abe
but it turns out there's a black blues
singer named lady a and she was like
you're a racist for stealing my name or
something there's just no there's no
winning but but I'll tell you right now
there's a um who's the other other
rapper Who's done Bryson gray is that
his name yeah so there's a bunch of
people who are outright calling at the
machine and they're gaining in
popularity so I think I think you can
push back I think that the pushback has
happened but correct me if I'm wrong I'm
a big fan of Tom McDonald but does he
play live I don't know I don't think so
I don't think and a lot of these artists
that are speaking out don't play live
and I wonder what the I see what you're
saying what the repercussion would be if
they were to play Live you know like you
need security you need yeah you know oh
yeah yeah we put on an event a few years
ago and anti some antifa guys called up
and threatened to burn the theater down
and so they waited till the very last
minute and the theater cancels on us so
we ended up moving the event to a casino
so the event still happens but it cut a
capacity down we did our after party in
the same place they show up they were
threatening us outright the cops like
we're not gonna do anything about it it
looks like Tom played live until October
2020 since October 23rd at JJ's Bohemian
Chattanooga Tennessee was his last show
according to
bandsantown.com I don't know or he's
just not listing them anymore I mean I'm
sure they love live performance but I
know what you mean it can get a bit
chaotic we got to get rid of these the
we we we're not getting rid of them but
we got it we gotta stop the cowards
because I know for a fact we went to
Blue Ridge Rock Fest it's huge it was
amazing
and I'm walking around and people are
like yo hey what up Tim you know a big
fan and I'm like oh wow band members
other stuff there were like four bands
that were familiar with IRL that were
fans of the show and I was really cool I
was like how is it that so many people
here even the performers are fans of our
show
how are they not speaking out
challenging this stuff just telling
everyone to shut it down I don't think
it's it's you know at a place like that
where I suppose if everybody already
agrees and they're like get that woke
crap out of here you know I understand
if they're not making it their entire
lives I don't necessarily want to go to
a rock show and be lectured to or
anything like that but I'm like how is
it that the industry still has to
Stranglehold when so many of the people
there reject the ideology but I guess
the end of the day they just say yes to
their managers or whatever the leaders
so that's where that's where it all
comes down to it's it's also the the
whatever whoever's leading the band to
if you have the the leader of the band
The the star of the show and you you
know someone who's a member is saying
they love you
quietly
the leader of the ACT might not think
like that also they might be programmed
by because they're usually they're the
ones dealing with the managers the
labels the it goes beyond that it really
it really is a deep entrenchment and and
if you want to continue to have almost
this meteoric rise or these
opportunities continue to come your way
you you have to comply if you stop
complying you find yourself
having to be independent or go on your
own or have to build a house out in the
middle of nowhere and be
self-sustainable right you're you're
exiled from the community uh in a sense
so I think to answer your question
the guitar player of a band may be like
I love you Tim
but he's not gonna go out and and say
that or do
what he feels because he could be kicked
out of the band by the the person that's
look at look at Pete Parada right so he
we worked on a song together we're gonna
work on a bunch of more songs with him
he's a former drummer of The Offspring
he goes to his doctor and doctor is like
yeah you can't get the vaccine because
you have you have a high risk for Gambar
right he's like oh man that sucks so the
offspring's like you're fired right he's
like bro like you don't even disagree
with him and the crazy thing is he
didn't disagree with them just like my
doctor says I can't get it and they're
like oh well dude you're fired and then
all the media writes is an anti-vaxxer
yeah these people are an occult man so I
can understand why people are scared for
sure but that's why I was like for one
it was it was awesome to work with Pete
because it's like I've been listening to
offering since I was a kid so it was an
honor to be able to have such a good
drummer plus he was in face to face and
he toured with a bunch of other bands
and uh but it was it was it was a huge
Market opportunity I'm like we get this
great drummer they're losing out but the
other thing is we want to make sure that
if someone does speak out and Pete
didn't really even do that but if they
are going to try and come after you that
we're going to be building an industry
of in some capacity that's going to be
like now you're not going to be left
destitute we're going to we're going to
work on right there will be a Ying to
the yang right it can't just be you're
exiled you're out here and now you're
getting rained on in the mud there has
to be another group of people that
welcomes you and supports you and and I
do agree with you I think that that's
growing and I think there's a community
of people that that are putting their
foot down because we we have to at this
point I think we're getting into a a bit
and I don't want to use the word
desperate times because I don't want any
fear Monger but I do think that we have
to start
speaking out about how we feel you know
us we have to start talking about we
can't be ashamed to say that we love
this country and we love Liberty and we
love freedom I don't know when that
became like like where you say that in a
room and no one likes you anymore right
like I don't there's a lot of things
that we're losing right now that that I
don't think is okay you know just like
country music you know what I mean I
mean it is look at you see John Rich put
out that song progress yeah yeah he's
just like sticker where the sun don't
shine and they're like yep and I'm like
well at least those that that whole
faction of people are are cool that
industry is is Trucking along it seems
like music industry in general has
always been about profit maybe not
always all but like since 1920 when it
didn't used to exist until radio like
they used to just play for food at night
and then that would be it that they
didn't were Rich at all and then they
started being able to control their own
well control their own couldn't really
control their own distribution that was
the labels came in and immediately were
like we're gonna control your
distribution so when the then then that
died off in like 2001 with Napster like
90 87 or something and then the artist
started to be able to control their own
distribution now yeah so it said but
that old that old network of people
still is trying to profit off of it but
so like now there's like an artist
distribution thing it's just diasporic
like there's they're all over the place
and there isn't like a unified it's very
cartelic though I just want to explain
when I use this word it's a very extreme
word cartel but I talked a little about
it earlier when we in trouble were
talking like the people in the music
industry will ruin someone's life and
lose no sleep over it and it takes a
certain type of person to do that right
they will they will shoot someone in the
head watch them drop dead on the floor
turn to their assistant and say what's
for lunch and not think twice about what
they've just done they will they will
take an artist who's a 20 year old kid
with dreams they will ruin his career
because of whatever reason they want to
and they will not think about it again
when they leave the room like for people
like us if if you hurt someone's
feelings or I love people I'm a people
person if I do something wrong to
someone
uh it bugs me right the the people
leading the music industry it doesn't
bug them they could literally ruin
someone's life and then never ever ever
think about it again yeah so they think
of artists as cattle basically yeah I
think it's more than I I think it's
beyond just money because there are very
talented very good people who don't get
any play on the radios or in the music
industry individuals like Lupe Fiasco he
was blowing up he was a major uh music
performer everyone loved him I
interviewed him along with Immortal
Technique at Occupy Wall Street and then
he went to Obama's uh unofficial
inauguration event and and while
everyone's there to celebrate Obama he
criticizes him in his drone policies and
and makes a song that literally has him
kicked out of the event and now of
course after that he doesn't get that
much play so individuals like Lupe
Fiasco Immortal Technique are
individuals that I listened to that
inspired me that are in the kind of
hip-hop cultural world but even rock
stars they're known as being
anti-establishment now they're like
super establishment remember when there
used to be this this really great band
they don't exist anymore I was a big fan
it was called what was it called rage
rage against the machine and now and now
it's like these days you know they're
not around there's a band that's just
called rage on behalf of the machine
correct so is it like because it used to
be Creedence Clearwater Revival talking
about you know Vietnam screw Vietnam get
the troops out War sucks and then when
Napster came out is it like there was a
moment where there was no music industry
for a minute and now they're like we're
just gonna get 14 year olds put them on
insane contracts and make them famous
they'll do whatever we say we'll just
pick people that want to be famous I
think I think John Lennon terrified him
you know because he's he's a this major
celebrity who's been like no to war and
they're like oh this is turning
sentiment against us and then all these
other bands follow look what happened
yeah yeah look what happened I think at
one point he said he might have said I
heard this that he said in public if I
ever get so famous that I forget why I'm
doing this somebody kill me and someone
took him literally they thought like
some crazy guy remembered that from 20
years ago and was like oh you did ask
did I make sure that he gets killed and
so someone that Mark David Chapman I
think was his name I want to I gotta
read one Super Chat you know we normally
save him for the end but I just gotta
read this one uh peripheral inkling says
Slipknot still wears masks when they
play maybe someone should tell them it's
safe now oh my gosh that was a good one
back to Rage Against the Machine because
I was a huge fan but remember their
album cover was Shea Guevara yeah that
dude's a Monster yeah yeah he is what
machine were they raging against yeah
the one that didn't support them and
then once they got power they were like
okay now we're good with the machine
that we built we are the machine Let's
jump to this next story we got a story
from variety uh Luke gradkowski's dad
Bill Maher says woke baggage is
Democrats biggest problem stop talking
about pregnant men man what a turn
around first the important thing he's
not really Luke's dad yeah and bladder
is not Luke's Uncle that's right
challenge if all three of them had a DNA
baby somehow I would pop out probably
about
but uh a few years ago
Dennis Prager goes on Bill Maher's show
and he's like they're claiming that men
can have periods and then Bill Maher is
like no they're not and he's like yes
they are and they're putting tampons in
the men's room and Bill Maher is like oh
it's for their girlfriends you're crazy
now Bill Maher is coming out and saying
like stop talking about pregnant men so
maybe I guess I can bring this up
because I think what happens with Bill
Maher is that he's kind of seeing the
writing on the wall he's like oh this
weird cult stuff is not popular and if
we keep embracing it we're going down so
uh he saw the writing on the wall he's
changing his tune and pushing back and
saying no to this I think this is a
white pill moment like we can talk about
the weirdo cult we can talk about
industry control but let's just say this
you got prominent HBO mainstream liberal
personality pushing back on wokeness
you've got Independent Artists gaining
traction expanding and pushing back on
the machine literally actually raging
Against the Machine and and succeeding
so I look at this like the weirdo
uniparty cult and ain't working out it's
it's fizzling right and I think a lot of
it is because it lacks common sense
right and it almost feels like a test of
how far what can we what can we program
these people to believe right like if
you're starting to lose common sense
like it's obvious that men can't
comprehend obviously it's it's like
right come on but it's almost like let's
run this test to see who we can convince
this and what part of people are
convincible convincible to do anything
right like you have people that are that
are jumping onto this right those are
the people that are unreasonable those
are the people that that no matter what
facts you show that are currently going
on they will deny the facts you could
you could show them you know data from a
year later
they'll deny the data you could show
them oh you know men can't get pregnant
oh I don't believe that you don't need a
show on that I mean it's ridiculous but
there's but it's crazy that's what I'm
saying it's like how far how far can we
program certain people it's almost like
a test it's almost like they're running
they're running tests to see how
convincible that's why I'm saying you
know simulation Theory baby we are in a
computer simulation and there's someone
sitting there going like okay let's
enter the parameters and let's now
introduce telling all of the Americans
that men can get pregnant I think
they're hacking 17 actually agreed with
that they're hacking the way people
think because like Darwin for instance
would say it's not the strongest of the
species that survives but the one that's
most adaptable to change and if people
change to believe psychosis that's part
of like we're able to do that if we need
to to survive for the moment let's just
pretend that eating the Frozen dead
bodies we've crash landed in the in the
Arctic let's pretend like it's normal
what everyone get like you've seen the
movie alive that group went down they
had to eat each other to survive you
know you just put yourself in a moment
of psychosis where like this is normal
we're gonna get through it and and then
For Better or Worse you know we've
basically accepted something that other
you might normally think is psychotic so
I think people have hijacked that with
social media and they're feeding it and
they're like Transit transiting people
or something it's what Stalin said so he
he had plucked all the hairs off this
chicken right and the others yeah all
the feathers yep thank you for that so
well you're the chicken master right I
don't have a chicken you know so so he
tortured this chicken and then after
torturing the chicken gave it a little
food and then the chicken followed him
around for the rest of the day he was
hungry and he essentially says it's like
you could torture people you could
torture animals you could you could
torture something and if you just give
it a little more so it'll it'll come
back to you for more and I feel like
we're being conditioned right now to to
you know the financial crisis that we're
being conditioned that that oh inflation
could be at 80 10 is not bad we're being
conditioned that we we oh we'll you know
you want your own apartment when you
can't afford it well just get two
roommates like we're being condition to
like lower standards of life you know
our standards of life like oh you're
working 40 hours a week you don't have
any money living in your car like well
there's a lot of people doing that so
you should be grateful that you're not
in the tent in Portland like do you see
what David Hogg said so for those who
don't you guys know David Hogg he's the
he's the one of the gun control activist
guys on Twitter and he said that uh he's
not gonna have kids he'd rather have a
Porsche or a Portuguese water dog and a
lot of people saw that tweet I retweeted
it and they were and you know I quote
tweeted him and said thank you for your
sacrifice David you're making the future
a better place you know but but you know
it goes both ways like fighting climate
change hey all right not having kids but
here's here here's people missed his
first tweet in the thread he said
something like
children are the new luxuries and what I
mean is it's something where you you
it's really difficult to have you can't
afford it so it's nice when your friend
comes by and shows it off but it's not
for you because you can't afford to have
it's like a boat yeah children are like
the modern day boat that's what he said
that's a way to take happiness of people
my children but that's a great thing
ever happened in my life and when I hear
someone you know go to that extent to
say like I'm not gonna have kids like
they're punching themselves that that's
him punching themselves I love my kids
so much it's such a gift and and it does
it selfishly does so much for me to have
my kids because I get to feel this this
love and I get this bond in this in this
connection that I think if that's the
direction they're going to go or they
want to push everyone into not having
kids and not experiencing that love and
not being able to spend time with family
I think that's a bad Direction I think
that's a bad Direction it's another
direction away from God it's another
Direction into the the the servitude
yeah the servitude the satanicism it's
just another another way to suck love
away from you or suck the the greatest
things in life out of your life it's
just the biggest gift denying it to
yourself because of some propaganda that
you heard because of some elitist
newspaper telling you that it's bad for
the environment which is absolutely
absolutely just an insane thought and
and just debunk on its basic premise but
but his point was it's like a boat where
it's like your friend has one it's fun
to go visit and see theirs but not have
one yourself and then he says I'd rather
have a Portuguese water dog he said what
did he say he also said something I mean
these are interesting points to be to be
made I I don't I don't agree necessarily
but he's making interesting points that
he's uh he was basically saying
a pet is a cheaper is cheaper than a kid
it reaches a certain point where it's
not going to get any more expensive you
don't got to pay for college a house
plant is cheaper than a pet you get it
you have it you take care of it but he's
he's actually making a really great
point for people who want something to
take care of child is one of the hardest
things but one of the most rewarding I
mean you're on your deathbed and you've
got a human being who loves and is
caring for you and making sure you're
comfortable on your way out a dog ain't
gonna do that but a poor dog is cheaper
a dog is cheaper so instead of spending
you know I think it's like 250 000 to
raise a kid or something you're spending
10 000 on a dog maybe then you can't
even you can't even deal with that level
of taking care of something because you
got a schedule letting it out so you get
a cat but then you don't really you know
maybe you can't afford the cancer get a
plant now the plant is like the lowest
level of caring for a life form but
they're also missing a huge point of of
what kids do to your motivation as well
most people will say that raising kids
are hard but once you have your kids
you're going to do anything anything you
have to do to give them the best life
and usually you become a better person
because of those kids and you you get
motivated to to work harder make more
money be a better family man yeah and
strengthen your spirit too I'm telling
you it brings you closer to God you have
kids you you you feel some form of
spiritual power within yourself and
connection to it to another being that
that helps you up up your level man you
level up and it's you know I walk around
in my in my 20s saying I'm never gonna
have kids and and you know spoke like
that and then and then you learn and and
I would say for anyone that
feels like they don't need to have kids
I do think you miss out on on a bit of a
spiritual connection with God you miss
out on just a love that that is just
Indescribable
um and the people that are going to be
by your bedside you know look my father
just passed away I love you Dad and it
was me and my brother with him and my
mom it was us yeah so uh we talked about
this about a lot of women
who are lying to themselves or are
scared to to to to express themselves
The Young Turks it's it's remarkable how
they can like take what I say and then
completely ignore what I say but show
what I say and then turn into something
I didn't say
so I said basically I'm sure most women
are happy to have their jobs and their
success and more power to them I have
tremendous respect to anybody male or
female they want to get you know get a
job and succeed but I but I think there
are some women and a lot of them that
really do just want to have families and
not be Breadwinners but are worried
about this because it's not so not as
socially acceptable anymore and they're
expected to have careers and with the
economy the way it is they have to work
so there's a lot of these women that are
either denying it they're lying to
themselves or they're too scared to
speak up but once they're older they're
going to regret it yeah they're going to
win now I'm not saying literally every
woman I'm not saying the majority of
women say there's a lot of women who are
probably experiencing this so take that
out of context Young Turks by all means
but I think it's true I think I think
the thing is for guys they can have kids
like there's like 70 year old dude can
have a kid Clint Eastwood did that I
mean you got four million little
soldiers firing off in each each attempt
and only only one of them needs to be
viable I hear the woman's body decides
which sperm implants the egg too
fertilizes the egg
has a window to you know um fertility
men also as well but not as severe as
women that by the age of 30 lose almost
90 percent of all the eggs that they had
throughout their entire life in
existence and even talking about this
it's a touchy subject because people
automatically get very emotional but I
think at the end of the day there's a
legitimate argument to make that a lot
of women have been brainwashed to serve
corporations rather than of course their
own families and I think that's
something that deserves to be talked
about deserves to be debated and you
know we could be wrong on this
particular topic but but again at least
let's have the conversation that's being
denied to everyone and having children
um is is something that gives a lot of
people purpose something that allows
people to have something greater than
themselves Charles art lovera he's a UFC
champion I love him he had a couple of
fights in his career he lost him he was
he won some but then he went on a streak
where he just dominated everyone he's
one of the best fighters right now in
the UFC and he attrib Buttes having a
child to him being on a trajectory and
on a purpose that made him that much
better than almost everyone else in the
division and he's dominating he's one of
the best fighters that the UFC has ever
seen and he attributes that to having
children so that's a power there that I
think is worth tapping into you just
gotta imagine the guy you're fighting is
trying to punch your kid yeah and then
you're just like Invincible the other
guy is fighting for sport you're
fighting for your kid I mean even in all
seriousness you're fighting against
somebody who doesn't have kids and none
of them do but like you're fighting for
someone who's passionate driven by sport
you're driven by protecting your family
you're probably gonna have a leg up on
on you know and then I'm reading the
comments here someone's telling me Oh I
was going to have my eggs frozen people
don't understand that that also leads to
a lot of problems and also has a very
big risk of of not working and you could
probably talk about this uh Lydia
because I think you did some research
into this as well oh I never looked at
freezing my eggs because I know that's
not a good idea but I have lots of
friends who've done IBS it's incredibly
painful it's a horrible process if you
can't avoid it you should I think we
need to emphasize getting married and
making families younger but it's a
cultural issue that I don't know if we
can change for the top down let's have
to see what happens when you were first
having kids Rick were you was did you go
through like a panic State yeah of
course it's just everyone goes through
the same process right you don't want
you you almost fear yourself out of
having them and then I mean we watched
it happen with our guitar player like
one year before he's telling me like I'm
just not meant to have kids man it ain't
in my cars I don't want them blah blah
blah you know like the whole speech and
I'm like I don't know man like when you
I told him I said when you have a kid
you're gonna think your kid's the
greatest that's all you're going to talk
about I don't think so if I called him
right now I'd be like what do you what
are you doing he's like hanging on my
little buddy he's the greatest you got
to see him he's already dude he's
already playing Stairway To Heaven on
the guitars one you know like like you
you like you said the the best sperm
gets into the door right so you're proud
you're you're pumped and and I uh you
know what Luke you were saying I think
that that it's in it's in our it's
embedded in women it's embedded in us to
have this this you know nature this this
motherly nature this fatherly Instinct
and I think women are just so great at
at family and my wife is amazing at
keeping our family together and helping
you know helping me lead and make me a
better person and it's just family is is
so important and I think that women are
so good at it that when when you're you
see corporations or whatever it may be
that's making them not want to have kids
or not want to experience that they're
they're not experiencing something that
they're just so so great at they're just
you know for for a husband to watch my
wife I'm just blown away all the time by
her ability to be uh so family oriented
such a great mother just so I could just
sit here all day but it's just a
characteristic of
great women you know I used to say I
didn't want to have kids unless I could
bring them around the world with me I
want to travel and go like how how have
you dealt with being on the road if you
win you two or with having kids if you
don't bring them along because I don't
know do you bring you I think we talked
before you say you don't bring them
along every time I don't bring them
along every time but I just I know I got
to provide for them and that's very
important and I know I got to provide a
good life and I think the way our
schedule is is I like it I like going
for two three weeks working so hard with
my best friends I'm gonna band with my
best friends you it gives me another
balance to my life we have a great time
together and then I get to go home and
be with my kids and my wife 24 hours a
day I don't gotta wake up and show up to
no job for eight hours take an hour
break when I get I get to be with my
family for two three months straight all
day every day and and the juice is worth
the squeeze to me so yeah I missed them
when we're traveling I miss them
um but oh do you video chat video chat
like while you're on the road yeah yeah
we're gonna jump to this next story
cancel culture baby Dilbert is racist
popular comic strip is canned by 77
newspapers after artist Scott Adams
began incorporating anti-woke plot lines
including black character who identifies
as white it's brilliant good job Scott
um I mean dude speaking out speaking up
and using his platform and they and they
come they come for him because of it now
they do say over the Daily Mail Gilbert
strips featured in newspapers I don't
know what Gilbert is but Dilbert's been
around forever
and so he's got a bunch of these Comics
one there's a guy and he's like Dave I
need to boost our company's ESG rating
so I'm promoting you to be our CTO I
know you identify as white so that won't
help our ASG scores but would it be too
much trouble to identify as gay it says
depends on how hard you want me to sell
it just wear better shirts oh my this is
great these Comics are actually they're
hilarious so there's one where it's like
I don't know if it's in here one of the
comics is that they're introducing a
black character and he's like I'd like
to introduce uh you know to our new uh
employee who's going to help bring our
ESG score up and then the black guy goes
identify as white and he's like you're
ruining this so anyway look
Scott Adams obviously has been outspoken
for a while now but directly
incorporating the stuff more and more
into his Comics so what do they do they
can the comics but you know what this
says to me it's just winning I know
there's a lot of people who are like
you're getting canceled from newspapers
do you think it's winning I do because
people like Dilbert there's going to be
a lot of people who are like yo where's
Dilbert and I'm willing to bet and and
if you're a fan of Dilbert I'm willing
to bet a lot of people are going to look
at their newspapers the ones that are
still reading it and be like where's
Dilbert and or the websites and they're
going to call up and be like hey where's
Dilbert and they're gonna be like oh we
were offended by it so we took it out
and they're gonna be like well I like it
bring it back well it also matters that
that you're here giving them more of a
platform too right like we talked about
the other side you get canceled up one
side another side brings you up and Rise
you up so that's a good you know doing
the right thing with the platform but
also what what makes me scared is how
the most powerful companies in the world
are the ones that are the Locust right
now that's that's concerning when you
look at who's
pushing
all the all the wokeness on us it's like
it's like Disney it's like it's like
ESPN this it's like wow these are like
powerful powerful players in media yeah
a little concerning well that's because
of the ESG score which he was
criticizing which he got canceled for
criticizing and I think that's more to
why he got canceled than any other
reason uh just yesterday at the Clinton
Global initiative Bill Clinton was
talking with the heads of BlackRock
promoting ESG as somehow some kind of a
great accomplishment it's awesome it's
great no it's literally a Ponzi scheme
for people to enrich themselves and push
ideas that divide and conquer people and
make them more dependent on the state
and and when you look at these funds
when you look at what what they're doing
it's absolutely Sinister because they go
to major corporations and say hey you're
gonna promote this idea you're gonna
push this agenda you don't we're gonna
cut your funding we're not going to give
you any money and the corporations
listen it's also just going to bolster
investment into China yeah absolutely I
wonder how alphabet's dealing with the
parent company of YouTube I haven't
talked to anybody there well parent
company of Google oh yeah which is a
parent company of I think alphabet owns
YouTube now I think it's a separate
company it could be alphabet owns Google
which owns YouTube but I'd love if
someone out there corporate wants to
come on the show and talk about it how
you guys are dealing with ESG I'd love
to hear it because Google alphabet's
like one of the most maybe the most
powerful media company on Earth right
now
the woke cult the ESG stuff only
operates as long as people don't know
about it once regular people find out
about it they get mad that's how that's
how you end up with a republican winning
in Virginia because people didn't know
was going to schools they found out
what's going on in schools and then they
were like okay I'm voting against this
and it was it was Suburban Housewives
they voted against Trump all of a sudden
they see what's going on they're like ah
it's worse the other direction
so I think this is why they got a sensor
it's why they're so adamant about
controlling what you guys post or what
other artists post especially for bands
this is why I'm saying culture is so
important because people just want to be
entertained they want to have a good
time they want to relax they don't want
to think about work they don't think
about hardship they don't think about
politics they don't want to be brought
down some people do some people love
Doom scrolling but a lot of people
they're like you know again I'll shout
out Blue Ridge Rockfest because we were
there just a couple weeks ago like two
weeks ago and the people who are there
are like I want to get out I want to get
away right and so they go in Mass to see
Tenacious D in the rain in the mud dude
I think it's sprayed down yeah
what did me too but so then they know
that these people up on stage at that
moment have a lot of influence because
you can look at a crowd and you can be
singing and then you point the
microphone and everyone in the crowd
knows it's their turn to start singing
so you go up on stage and pull up John
Lennon and say this war in Ukraine is BS
and we shouldn't be involved and people
are going to be like do I cheer for that
or like what I like I like this band so
I'm in I guess that's what they didn't
like about John Lennon and that's why I
think TV shows you know movies actors
the Arts they they lock that down and
made sure everybody was Marching In
lockstown they tried but John was
Unstoppable man could not be stopped
dude
everyone stopped eventually you know
everyone dies eventually but John Legend
was young he was so famous that the
media couldn't stop like they would
still go to his apartment with him and
Yoko in bed like what was it a sleep in
for peace they were doing like yeah when
that happens they get ready it seems he
was stopped I mean I don't know there's
a bunch of wild theories but I can just
say that some some way or another like
dude was stopped
by John Mark Chapman you mean or is that
Mark David Mark David John Mark Chapman
who the hell is that uh Mark David
Chapman yeah yeah I don't know I don't
know I mean maybe maybe someone sent
Chapman after him maybe because he was
so anti-war or yeah it was just crazy
you start thinking when you when you get
when you dive so deep into the layers of
of you you know obviously listening to
the show hanging out with you guys you
you you're getting informed right you're
learning more you start questioning
everything that you see when you see
Lenin's death when you start when you
start putting pieces together of of
influential people that have passed away
and the the messages that they were
standing for Anytime someone's uniting
people bringing people together going
anti-war they don't last very long and
and you and it makes you start really
wondering like wow like am I a
conspiracy theorist or
is this just how it is when you get too
influential where you're bigger than the
media you're Larger than Life you're
spreading this message that's bringing
people together people love making
people love each other yeah yeah
become a problem Kurt Cobain had a tweet
where he said he had evidence that would
lead to the arrest and then you know
what uh Martin Luther King Jr actually
uh his family filed a civil someone's
gonna clip that that was a joke media
matter is gonna be like Temple thinks
Kurt Cobain had Twitter the I think it
was uh Martin Luther King Jr Stanley
filed a civil suit against the FBI for a
wrongful death didn't they like send him
a letter telling him to kill himself or
something that was the FBI under their
cone tell probe program when MLK was in
jail they they actually called his wife
uh and played the audio recordings of
MLK cheating on his wife and they also
sent letters to MLK in jail saying kill
yourself
so this is this is what this is what the
FBI but this is what the FBI was doing
decades ago and not
the heart attack gun uh yes that was
with uh the commission this is why
people think Breitbart was killed
because he was really young and he was
extremely influential a lot of drugs too
for sure for sure I heard he was a big
partier right right right right right
but I'm saying the reason people I'm not
saying he was killed I'm saying the
reason people think it is because you
have someone influential in politics and
then you go back five decades and they
have a heart attack gun and you're like
yeah okay well it's possible I guess and
it's really funny because then the media
like you can cite the media and then the
me and then other journalists will then
claim your espousing conspiracy theories
is the weirdest thing you'd be like hey
look at this story in the New York Times
about a heart attack gun and then
they'll write a story about you saying
you're an unhinged conspiracy theorist
talking about heart attack guns and it's
like I was just reading the newspaper
dude come on man leave me alone you know
yeah but I wonder what you guys
listening think do you think like Lennon
you know John Lennon and like JFK were
were removed you know or or I mean
obviously they both were but was it like
overt high level politics or was it lone
weirdos well now when you see the media
you get behind something so hard like
some of the some of the things we've
seen like I haven't brought it up the
other day like and I know that this is a
bad example but but it makes you think
of the DC sniper right that guy that was
just on the side picking picking people
off once you start seeing how much the
media went in on that story used when
does the media go that in on something
unless they want to manipulate the tale
of the story right so it makes you start
thinking like
was that guy exiled right was he in the
system at some point learned some
information exiled out like is that
another instance to this like you you
start looking at all the things in your
life that you're growing up for me one
of them is JFK Lenin's another one you
got Chris Cornell you got uh Chester
from Lincoln Park you you you you hear
rumors about some of the things that
they are going on in a sense of of
really trying to help eliminate child
trafficking and and this is real man
these are these are stories that we're
hearing from their families from people
we know that know them they were heavily
involved in really helping you know
I suppose it yeah and then and then they
disappear so it's like it's like I'm
sure it's it's a it's a give and take
some of it happened some of it didn't
but you start questioning it all dude
Charles Manson's another interesting
when he was part of MK Ultra I believe
it was MK Ultra I wrote a book about it
this guy wrote this massive book he's
been on Rogan multiple times let's fact
check if that's correct here because we
know the Unabomber was a part of the MK
Ultra programs which are secret uh
programs by the CIA that was doing
horrific human experiments trying to
figure out mind control so this is done
documented on the record your tax
dollars went towards the CIA and they
experimented on on a lot of people who
were unsuspecting subjects and they were
given acid they were given a whole bunch
of drugs that they couldn't handle a lot
of people even died under CIA
experimentation but the CIA decades and
decades ago all the way in the 60s and
70s was working on controlling people's
minds and getting them to do things for
them so this is not a conspiracy this is
this is real this is this happens all my
family and friends listening right now
get your minds blowing aren't you
this uh the guardian has this article
chaos Charles Manson the CIA and the
secret history of the 60s by Tom O'Neill
with Dan pipe and bring review I think
there was a book and I I'll see if I can
find the book title did the cia's LSD
Labs make Manson the crazy because he
would like get arrested and then they
would let him out and then he'd go and
get arrested again and they'd let him
out again you know not like that like
they never happens I know but here's
here's Ted Kaczynski in the Unabomber
was the big one now here's a question is
a very interesting story here's a
question for you Luke uh you you made
the Bold Claim about the uh Satanist
influence in the music industry and we
hear a lot of this stuff from back in
the day about like playing records
backwards and there's like a secret
message but what's going on what what
what information I I don't ever claim to
know what's going on I just have a lot
of questions that I think should be
answered questions I think I think
specifically people in the music
industry you know are exposed to a lot
of The Insider dealings that that we
don't we we aren't preview to and that's
why I was kind of looking to ask you
guys what you you guys seen because I I
think it's pretty clear there is some
kind of satanic demonic influence
whether it's just done as parody or
whether there's some deeper meaning to
it you see the lyrics you see the
symbology and it's and it's overt and
you see a lot of the same things a lot
of the same lyrics saying I sold my soul
to the devil I don't I don't claim to
know exactly what's going on here but
being in the music industry how do you
guys well real quick I'm going to get a
button for my stream deck that plays a
sound bite from Boondock Saints when um
Willem Dafoe says symbolism
when the guy says symbology that's a
good movie that's a good movie so yeah
what's going on man so we we see it too
I mean look at the biggest artists in
the world are getting on the MTV Movie
Awards and then you look at the
subliminal messages behind you look at
even Disney uh you know they did
something in the Cruella Deville Movie
that that you know had like Satan on the
front on entrance of her house like that
you know what I mean or the car like
like there there's all these little uh
devil references and then and and music
listen to the lyrics listen to some of
the most popular artists in the world
you got Billy eilish with a title her
song is called I'm the bad guy right
what little my daughter is listening to
that she's seven eight years old I'm the
bad guy dad you know like you you've got
the most popular rappers talking about
overdosing on drugs you've got these are
the messages
that the kids listen are falling into
right that that's first of all those are
the biggest artists in the world that
promote they're promoting and then you
look at the the fashion side of things
what was his name little Nas X is on
there with blood in his shoes and the
club they're they're what are they
called the their their hoes they have
the the split in the top
cloven dressed in all red dress then
they also say there's Satanic rituals
with the with the white and black floors
in the videos like if you look at some
of the biggest artists in the world like
it might be Jay-Z might be one of them
you know you almost gets scared to say
some of these people's names when they
shoot the videos they say that that they
they shoot some of these videos on the
black and white floors and all this
stuff like these places are where like
like rituals happen whether there have
been like sacrifices like you you hear
these rumors in the music industry and
and I don't think a lot of it's rumors I
think that there is but but check us out
something changed and maybe it was an
anomaly but I remember when I was little
the first CD I ever got Americana
offspring and so they have a hit song
it's huge song it's called The Kids
Aren't all right the song is literally
just lamenting the demise of like the
family and Urban Decay it's literally
him singing a song about how these kids
you know nothing's free you know uh
chances Throne longing forward it used
to be like wanting to go back to another
time people doing drugs getting pregnant
dropping out that's what the song's
about and it's negative depictions of
that they had another song on that album
that that was a huge hit why don't you
get a job and then I'm like you know I'm
thinking about this a few years ago and
I was like man those guys were actually
pretty conservative by today's standards
then they put out a song a few years
later called hit that which is a song
lamenting the fact that lamenting hookup
culture and that people aren't getting
married anymore and I'm liar these guys
are like strangely traditionalist but of
course now today they're like you're
fired from the band because dude could
not get a vaccine but it's just weird to
see that back in the 90s the you know
aside from Pretty Fly for a White Guy I
don't know bunch of songs on that album
that are just literally you know like
have a family and get a job you know and
don't let your kids do drugs I I gotta
say I think Satan gets a bad rep uh
Lucifer in general I think well person I
don't like it and I don't like evil and
I don't like blood magic I get pretty
turned off by those things but I think
the propaganda of the Bible is like
there were some cultists they were
taking psychedelics Michael the
Archangel and Lucifer and all these
dudes taken and they were channeling God
communicating but Michael was the leader
and eventually maybe they were hoarding
knowledge that they were like it's too
dangerous for them they can't have the
light they can't have fire you can't
teach them how to make fire or maybe his
electricity can't give him flashlights
and Lucifer is like no you can't hoard
Knowledge from people so we went and
he's the lightbringer he brought the
Common People the ability to make light
sane and Lucifer are different so
Lucifer I'm talking about and
luciferianism or whatever and then so
he's like and they cast them out and
then they demon they win they go to war
there's a war over it and then that
Michael wins his cult wins and then they
write a Bible about a book about it and
make him the debt the most evil thing
first cancel culture ever or the first
one is luciferous the first canceled I
don't know man it sounds like propaganda
in yeah sure does look at Britney Spears
look at no you sound like profit oh well
it's all propaganda and you know
Brittany has come out and and you know
the media will cover every single time
her hair is a mess in public or every
time that she makes a video where she
looks like she had a glass of wine but
she came out and did an entire interview
about how she was at Satanic rituals in
the music industry that she was at
events where they did this they had
orgies with masks on she was at she that
came out and had said that she's seen
this up with her eyes no media coverage
no one talked about it nothing but you
will see media coverage on when she
looked crazy on Tick-Tock doing a dance
so it it's it's an interesting is it
bloodline
a lot of those Disney stars uh that that
were brought up in the industry and
became famous later on in their life a
lot of them are dealing with some
significant problems especially with
their upbringing especially with the
industry that brought them up and a lot
of them do talk about a lot of abuse
that happens to them which I think is
important important to note and
important to talk about I don't know if
you guys have any insights to that
particularly well now just the same as
you right you hear you hear all the
people the child stars of of our eight
of the 80s and 90s you know we're all
paranoid and they tell their stories
about what happened to them they were
you know like I think everyone knows the
elephant in the room is that there are
certain certain groups of powerful
people in this world that like children
right I mean I can't attest for any of
the theories that's a fact at this point
I mean right yeah I mean I I have
personal friends that literally do them
sold their soul to the devil to become
the best guitar player in the world and
their lives are ruined so but they think
they did is that what it is they would
they would prick their finger put it put
their blood on a contract write a
contract out sign it and they said I
sold my soul to the devil to become the
greatest guitar player in the world and
now they're druggies somewhere and you
know yeah in the street whether you
believe Satan or not that person's life
is ruined for what they believed in I
don't like blood magic because blood's
fascinating and people work with it like
my girlfriend works with blood she like
does like diabetes will like put people
up to machines and stuff I think Cara if
I'm getting that wrong sorry about that
um but she works with it and it's like
it's a fascinating substance but like
Maria Abramovich does like blood sick
cooking where they like paint blood
spear cooking and it's like to get
fascinated with blood to love blood is
one thing we all got it but to get
obsessive with it is [ __ ] crazy
yeah we're like you can't do it without
the because it's got It's magnetic
there's iron in it so it's Gotta that's
why we have these magnetic you know
um dynamos so these these magnetic
fields the big part is because the iron
and the blood man like an X-Men when
Magneto was like too much iron in the
blood and then rips it out of his body
and then he makes little things and he's
like flying around yeah they get magic
is magnetic that mag you know prefix uh
well there's a lot of people that even
go as far as to compare music to mind
control because of the repetitive nature
of it because of the symbology because
of the lyrics because people listening
and also seeing it as a form of
entertainment which of course makes them
put their guards down and they're able
to of course subconsciously pick up a
lot of the larger messaging so there's a
lot of conversations about that
specifically I don't know if you guys
are aware of it but another thing I
wanted to also if you want to enter if
you want to go go right ahead but but
another thing I also wanted to talk
about is a lot of artists and a lot of
creative people usually say that their
music or their art they're usually just
a vessel for it and somehow when they're
creating music or art they have
something else speak kind of through
them you see this kind of described a
lot by a lot of very creative people I
don't know if you guys have any kind of
examples of 100 yeah I feel like
uh when when I talk about the the most
successful songs I've ever had and that
I've written in my life I I have to
attach the word blessed to it because
these these ideas came to me through
like like I'm a vessel right like like
whether it's full Melodies choruses
lyrics everything just like it just
happens and then it changes my life and
then and then it changes the the lives
of the listeners the fans I've had the
most fulfilling stories I've ever gotten
uh uh you know money money aside like
the things that that have really
fulfilled me the most in music is when
someone comes up and says uh your song
Somebody wishes they were you changed my
life it made me look at life differently
you know I really appreciate and have
more gratitude now where I was thinking
of doing something bad to myself and
then you know I heard some crazy stories
along the way I was thinking about doing
something bad to myself
this song came on I never heard of you
before it spoke to me and then I went
into a rehab and and changed my life
like these are the stories that are
Priceless to me these are the stories
when we were out on the road and we were
getting robbed for everything we had you
know working nine months out of the Year
going home and nothing you know because
we were selling all these terrible
contracts
um these were the stories that I'd lay
in bed and I'd say you know what man you
might not have any money you might be
working hard you might be you know
sacrificing all your relationships with
your lifelong friends your wife your
family but you're making an impact on
people's lives and and that drove me for
for years and yes it was the vessel that
that helps write these songs I can
definitely say that there is a spiritual
connection between being the vessel to
writing songs and connecting to people
and it definitely uh energetic one that
can't be really described in words and a
lot of people have a hard time even
quantifying in in sentences because it's
it's how do you describe this kind of
this feeling this emotion that overtakes
a lot of people even when they listen to
a particular song which of course is
usually connected with their emotions so
there's there's still so many other
things I want to ask you there's also of
course the the 432 Hertz conspiracy I
don't know if you guys heard of that one
uh but the key event there's a lot of
different stuff out there but uh you
know we're just touching we're just
touching the surface when you drum does
it take over you
yeah at a certain point I mean when a
performance starts your your focused and
then I mean you could just contribute
that to Adrenaline as well you know like
Kate turns into a different person when
he drones I see it every night I see it
every night there's another there's a
there's like a suit you watch someone go
like super saiyan you know like when
Dragon Ball Z characters would like hit
the hit the gas and their hairs would go
like blonde and they'd have a whole
energy Aura that's what it's like
watching him drum for for 15 years for
me man I see him start going and and and
people are like you guys got so much
energy on stage it's because he's he's
feeding me who already has all this
energy I'm feeding the crowd it's like
our our shows our live shows are like a
ball of energy circulating throughout a
room and and you know let's talk about
that that 400 Hertz conspiracy what is
that about Luke well there's different
theories out there I haven't looked into
it that much but there's a theory that
music used to be in a healing frequency
and then it was turned into a freaking
that's more disruptive you might know
more about this than I do because I just
looked at the surface level it's either
it's one of those uh World Elite
Rothschilds or something that changed
the standard tuning from 432 Hertz to
440 Hertz
um 432 Hertz
brings out the harmonic Resonance of the
notes and you get a lot more harmonics
and saturation and and the musical notes
and all original music like Beethoven
all those Original Classic composers
played in fourth to 432 Hertz their
pianos were tuned to 4 32 Hertz
um
even the Beatles did some 432 Hertz
music as well oh my God I pulled it up
here we got it from Global News the
great 440 Hertz conspiracy and why all
of our music is wrong
they say gather around kids those of you
with tin foil hats may wish to ensure
that they're fitted snugly what I'm
about to tell you will shake your faith
and all the music you've heard in your
life if you look down the right paths it
becomes clear that governments and
various security apparatuses have used
music to control us oh no
all the music of the West it's based on
the Standard 12 tone scale is used for
the management of crowds so as well as
thought control
they say if musical performances were to
sound the same the world over some
standardization was required as early as
1885 the music Commission of the Italian
government declared that all instruments
and orchestras should use a tuning fork
that vibrated at 440 Hertz which was
different from the original standard of
435 and the competing 432 used in France
in 1917 the American Federation
musicians endorsed the Italians followed
by a further push for 440 Hertz in the
40s in 1953 a worldwide agreement was
signed signatories declared the middle a
on the piano be forever more tuned to
exactly 440 Hertz this frequency became
the standard ISO 16 reference for tuning
all musical instruments
so what is it they say no one can say
for sure why so what's the conspiracy
what are you writing about well that's
like it's driving people crazy adherence
this Theory claimed the more natural
frequency or middle a is 438 others
believe the correct middle is 432
because there's a pure tone of math
fundamental to Nature and is
mathematically consistent with the
patterns of the universe vibrating with
fee Phi the golden ratio
they point to how this pitch can be
connected to everything from Nautilus
shells to the works of the Ancients
including the constructs of the Great
Pyramid that proves it so it's time to
change all of our tunings the reason I
brought this up is because I saw a
scientific experiment I think like 20
years ago when I was a child and it had
a box of sand and it put it over a
speaker and it played different uh hurts
and it different and it played a
different music and you could see the
shape of the hurt of the music that was
translated from the grains of sand that
were moved through the speaker and some
of the sand was very disruptive and all
over the place and really nasty and some
of it looked like snowflakes uh pure
perfect uh synchronistic images and you
know this is where we get into a lot of
the bigger kind of deeper hippie dippy
stuff when it comes to uh what the bleep
do you know and other kind of
documentaries like what are the great
mystery that of course talk about this
in great detail when it comes to
um you know perfectly aligned alleged
healing for frequencies and that's what
we hear sometimes again I'm not an
expert in this I just remember this
sitting here from 20 years ago it's
called chimatics is where you use sound
to alter matter what we're going to say
so like when you tune from 440 to 432
that's 32 cents lower so
it it gives it more of a slower feeling
as well so I create meditation
relaxation music with elevated and
everything's tuned to 432 Hertz and that
works better for that style of music
when you want to chill and you want to
relax
440 could could be you know leveling it
up to give a more energy you know it
might not be no crazy conspiracy theory
stuff it could just be like hey we want
more energy like I know that um Kiss
From a Rose
that's still right he he wanted his song
without changing the tempo to have more
energy so he brought up his two and he's
like 442 so he brought it up because he
wanted to give it more energy with just
tuning it up just a slight yeah I mean
to the to the to like the untrained ear
you can't really tell not even from 4 40
to 4 30 you can't really tell it's more
of a feeling yeah soul and feeling is is
so important that's why I think that it
could be a little I don't know enough
about it but I know I write from like
the just just the soul and I don't
overthink that stuff too much when I'm
going into a key or a range so and I
know that that that's worked so maybe
there's a lot of ways to eat a Reese's
right you know yeah like I mean think
about colonization of of the Native
American population by the Europeans
where the Native Americans chilling in
432 and but Native Americans were 432
and and so it didn't the Native
Americans were 432. if you buy if you go
get it like a natural made Native
American flute and naturally comes in
fourth or two Hertz and they weren't out
there engine nearing weapons and I mean
they were they had their own types but
not like the Europeans not like
gunpowder and explosives and physics to
shoot cannons and like just that aggro
go go go conquer take I wonder if that's
it there was Native American tribes that
were like that Ian that did conquer
other tribes that did were very
combative that that did enslave other
populations that did conduct human
sacrifices they were way more brutal
than Europeans brutally yeah but not
technologically advanced they would rip
people starts out on the top pyramids
calling in their entities because they
wanted better farming but it's like the
aggravation that prompts engineering
like I got to figure it out something's
wrong I got to figure it out where I was
like yo something's wrong no something's
fine everything's cool just chill like
that's the Native American style whereas
the European would be like something's
wrong let's fix it
I'm generalizing too of course but
that's just not absolutely not true yeah
you're talking about a wind a population
that that solely lived in in you know
areas with winter save the Mediterranean
and then you have North America with a
wide range of different temperatures
especially in like the desert or the
South where it's typically hot Native
Americans lived in Florida where it's
tropical so these things play a huge
role in whether or not someone needs to
strive towards something you live in
Florida you don't got to worry all that
much because the growing season is every
day of every year but for Europe the
growing season is they've got to deal
with winter that means if you don't work
you don't survive that's why they get
technological advancements there's no
there's no rage around it was heavily
populated too they're true because after
that flood 13 000 years ago that that
flood wiped out Native American wiped
out America like all the population of
the of North America got smear at least
the United States got smeared into tar
by that glacial flaw I'm pretty sure
that's not true I'm pretty sure that
there was a massive pandemic that wiped
out most of the new America I'm talking
about 13 12 800 years ago at the end of
the last uh younger dryas uh Randall
Carlson's the guy to go to for the
geological surveys on this stuff but
there's a layer of black sediment tar
where all the megaphone of the giraffes
and stuff were just smeared into dirt no
no I'm sorry I'm sorry you're wrong
because everyone knows everybody knows
that there was already a great
civilization that was here and this mud
flood can't dance swept through and then
buried those buildings and we we were
only discovering them that's why
Chicago's underground that proves it so
my final question is should we return
the music to 432 yes
I hereby decree From This Moment forward
do you guys have your music in that
frequency or do you guys have a I don't
know because when you get a snark a
tuner you put on your guitar it tells
you that a is what it is now it's just
measuring 440. nowadays it's very
difficult to to do your music in 440
because all the virtual instruments are
naturally tuned to 440 so if you're 432
I mean yeah 432 yeah so if you're gonna
go in and put virtual instruments on on
your recordings you literally have to
tune everything down to 432 and it they
make it really difficult
talking about that proves it's a
conspiracy that's right maybe when you
talk about the brutality of History like
he's talking about like people were over
overrunning civilizations and doing that
doesn't make doesn't it make you feel
like our our generation is being
conditioned to not be prepared for
anything like that like like if you're
if right now I feel like if if I said to
someone I'd be ready to fight for my
household or I'd be ready to defend
Trevor or you know do whatever I would
be looked at in a negative light right
it would be like oh
he's he's a toxic male or whatever it
may be right it feels that way nowadays
uh when I'm when you get ready for
nothing right when you're like
defensively prepared for Stuff uh it
almost feels like we're being softened
up
pretty pretty bad Our Generation I don't
know and when you talk about history
back in the day like people were
brutalizing colonies and doing all this
stuff it's in history and and now you've
got it like it's it's so frowned upon to
be ready for anything like that so
you're like a loser but just really
quick many people don't understand how
blessed and how absolutely lucky we are
especially here in the United States
especially living here you you travel
the world other people are not living
like this we are fully over abundant and
we are living an extremely to the
contrary good times good times that
leads to weaknesses weak men that leads
to bad times and I think we're on that
precipice where we're going into the bad
times that's why we all have a
responsibility to maintain the
awesomeness of the United States so we
can help the rest of the world when
Shay's rebellion was snapping off in
1778 all these farmers were like no I'm
I don't have the money to pay off your
debts to France we can't they try to
seize their property the farmers like
hell no they went to the courthouses
they surrounded them
they'd shut it all down people were
getting hurt uh they ended up but
whatever they they someone sent Thomas
Jefferson a letter and they were like yo
it's popping off there's a rev it looks
like there's gonna be a revolution
Thomas Jefferson was like good good we
need revolutions it keeps the government
honest
yeah that was his response you used like
you said it's great here and and you
could use the rest of the world as an
example but it also puts a little fear
in you right we don't I don't want that
here I don't when I think about the
civilians of a place like China I feel
so bad for them I feel like when is a
superhero going to go and and liberate
them right like I just don't want I
think that that we're not getting closer
to those people being you know freed
from this tyranny I think we're getting
closer to being
run by tyranny in a sense except our
generation right now us uh the people
listening the next batch of people that
are that are that are ready to just
speak about it
openly talk about what's happening and
and be as prepared as you can be right
we don't want to to go to war do
anything crazy right obviously that's
that's what it seems the the powers that
be want but we can't just not be ready
and we can't just not be you know
understanding that in the rest of the
world it's this type of way and we're
the only place that isn't that type of
way like my fear is losing
how great it is and what we have losing
our Liberty losing our freedom who who
is if we're all being conditioned and
not be ready to fight for that or ready
to to stand up for these things and
we're always just standing down who can
be brave yeah we have a gift and we're
taking it for granted the First
Amendment the Second Amendment is rare
of many civilizations many countries
many empires never had those kind of
Liberties that they allowed citizens to
have a part of their organizations now
in the first time one of the first times
we're experimenting with freedom and now
there's a Sinister group that wants to
take it away from us which is absolutely
insane it's amazing you know I was
reading uh I read some blog a while ago
and they're just talking about how all
of these these Kings were just like the
inheritors of authority and these all
this monarchy and they were Warlords and
people who just said they were the ones
who had the right and then along comes
for like the first one of the first
times in history a group of people who
are like nah or at least the first time
in a long time and they're like we are
not we we do not believe you have Divine
Providence Providence and you can speak
to God and you are not not the the world
is created by you know governments are
are for up and by the people so they
break away it kind of feels like
you know the powers that be really
regret losing control of the United
States and then you end up with uh who
is a Woodrow Wilson this SOB he comes in
and he basically says Central Bank hands
power right back to powerful special
interests
and then from there they've they've
really been upset about this whole
Constitution thing right you know the
whole right to keep in bear arms that's
a big thorn in their side the power
powerful is when I mean by they I mean
like generally just people who want to
control you want to manipulate you and
they come in all shapes and sizes I'm
not saying there's like any specific
group of people this is why if they're
beginning to show I brought up order in
chaos because property rights the right
to defend your property that's freaking
chaotic man if if you can't find people
can't find food everyone's defending
their property like who's in control
well no one's in control Community
though you need Community if you if you
keep your community strong that's the
key to everything if you if you don't
let the noise of what the media is
saying and the noise of everything going
on in the world and you you have strong
communities that are willing to help
each other with the food when something
goes bad stick together take care of
each other not not look to Rob each
other and do all this be criminals about
it but communities that come together
then then all those problems are solved
you know I think that that I don't know
it's it's just I feel like everything
that I say is is looked at negatively
these days right I trust in God I love
Community I love people if you go and
you say that
on anywhere on on Twitter on social
media like you'll get attacked you're
right about Community what we need to
look at the global Community because
what they're trying the world economic
Forum wants to create a global economic
order a community a global community and
they're just doing it the way that they
think Klaus is very much about order and
structure he's an engineer
um and but we need chaos we need
organized chaos that's what the United
States is well they've said out loud
that they believe they're a superior
species to us those Elites you're
talking Klaus you named them he he has
quoted and him and his scientists and
his crew of people they have quoted
saying that they are a higher power
human than we are we we are the basic
human they are the Superhuman that's
their belief there's about three
thousand four thousand people in the
world that believe they are another
species above us you and me and that's
why they think they're allowed to just
do what they're doing talk about putting
chips in us and whatever whatever they
want to do right you talk about the
world economic Forum they believe
they're a superior uh human breed than
we are it's the elite and the pleb which
is basically since the dawn of the time
they've done the leaders and the slaves
and then it was the leaders and the
civilians and then it was the leader the
elites and the common man and then
there's the better man who doesn't want
to be smarter better than someone else
right you play basketball against
someone you think you're better than
them but everyone thinks that they just
think they're better than us but is that
a fact that is not a fact that's just
their opinion that they think they're we
are a super breed of a human it's like
well I'm sure you think you're a super
beat of a human too you think you're
awesome you think you're awesome we all
think we're awesome it's just like that
doesn't work you don't get to rule the
world just because you think you're a
superior breed to us we're we're in a
task now to wake people up to their
potential because we are all awesome and
we're creating a global community of
awesome right
we have to do it we have to we have to
do it organize and talk about people in
the United States because this
constitution is badass I have faith in
this generation I I don't think we we
lose all all this I don't think Doom and
Gloom I have so much Faith In Our
Generation it starts with this room you
guys and everyone that's listening but
it's I have faith in this generation we
are going to make this world a better
place by the time it's all said and done
and we're going to be part of something
great and I firmly believe that and and
that's just that's just gonna stay my
mentality I'm not going to let any of
this stuff bring me down I'm gonna I
like being informed obviously why we
listen to the show uh when we're also
driving on tour we love you guys but
also to be a part of this community of
the Next Generation that's going to make
change for the world that's going to
make the world a better place in the
metaverse are you going in you guys
going to hook up your brains and
whatever they need help on the inside
you got to help them emotionally yeah
what if what if uh a whole generation of
people are trapped in the metaverse you
wouldn't go in you wouldn't pull a Neo
and try and go in and bring them out I
mean you just unplug the power you go to
the that's all you got to do you don't
gotta go in California the power's not
even going to work so we're not going to
be in the metaverse there they're gonna
have no grid there no I I'll go in the
metaverse to to perform concerts for for
the people there because we love people
we love we love our fans we love people
whatever we can do to help people will
do but you won't find me in the
metaverse for any other reason besides
uh maybe putting on a performance for
him I love people in real life I was
surprised that you played Portland
yeah that's dangerous it was and it was
tough to see it made me sad that's what
I'm saying that's why we're out here
speaking out we're we're out on the
ground floor we're seeing San Francisco
Portland Chicago we're seeing these
great cities that are that are just
crumbling from the inside and and I
don't care about anything except the
people the the civilians My People Are
People right our friends are it's just
it's just you see them living in tents
on the streets you see them homeless you
see them starving you know that
everything going on right now is not
good for these people and and I do lose
sleep at night uh thinking about all the
people uh that are struggling especially
in these places like Portland that we
play like I left Portland I was down and
sad for three or four days thinking
about all those people I saw living in
tents and they were starving that were
and I don't think that's a great
direction for this country some people
get mad at me for saying that I don't
want everyone in trailer homes intense
starving on the streets with no money
paying you know 13 for Lattes or
whatever whatever it may be I don't you
know people will get mad either to pay
13 for a latte it's like Ugh
you jerk I think those people are ripe
for metaverse for the Pickens what
they're gonna throw in metaverse yeah
they're gonna take a proprietary
software and then have a bunch of people
plug in and not they're gonna forget
they're in there and someone's gonna
have to go in and bend the software code
with their mind to realize people this
is Matrix bro
yeah people in the chat room are saying
you're speaking at 420 Hertz oh good
hell yeah now we're talking it took me a
second to catch up because you know 420.
that's a cool movie idea though it's
like
kind of like the Matrix but it's not
it's not like a dude breaks free from
The Matrix is that there are there is a
whole regular world of of Base reality
and then there are people who live in
The Matrix who live in the metaverse and
don't realize it
and so it's just like I'm at you know in
The Matrix you have the robots in base
reality and life sucks but imagine
normal life and then a group of people
that are just born into the metaverse
and don't know it and it'll happen is
that uh software Engineers will know the
code so well they'll just know software
code so well that they'll see software
happening and they'll be able to reverse
engineer How It Was Written and that's
how they'll bend the code without
knowing what it is and what if you're in
a simulation and we now have the ability
to do that and you can actually do some
Doctor Strange BS and you know
manipulate reality
that would be that'd be that'd be a cool
film as well you know it's kind of like
you know reality is
a simulation some dude figures out the
code are they trying to make AI where
we're like when you're on Facebook and
you're on all these social medias like
it'll it'll act as if it's your dead yes
yeah Alexa I think that would affect
Alexa stop
I'm talking about whoever's listening
what their speakers all right I feel
like that that would be you know I love
my mother you know we just lost my dad
it I feel like that would affect her
that would that would draw her into to
believing
that this artificial intelligence I
don't want to say her specifically but
people right who have dealt with loss I
don't think that's healthy I think
that's that that you could easily be
like oh I've been talking to my uncle on
in on Facebook it's you know like you
could people think that men can get
pregnant now you don't think that
artificial intelligence can convince
people that that is them I just watched
a wild video on AI and yeah it will be
able to convince people that it's real
and it may actually become terrifying to
me it's tracking that these Amazon
machines are are listening actively and
our phones are listening they're mapping
uh our personalities right now so that
when we're gone we'll be available still
whether or not it'll be emotionally
Salient I don't know I mean emotions AI
clones of you like ai's gonna have
emotion in that it's gonna be moving
it's going to be circuitry that's in
motion so there will be some semblance
of emotions
you'll be complying it'll be it's done
by big Tech so your AI emotion will just
be like men can have babies
think about it hey but think about how
crazy it's going to be when they create
artificial life forms like when they
make Android humans that you can't tell
they're so indistinguishable and that
they have AIS in them they will they
will there will be like a small child
please don't go outside during the
quarantine I don't want to get sick oh
please please don't and you're gonna be
like staring at this little kid and then
like I had this thought people are going
to be like uh video about this I got to
say it on the show that they're where
we're about to program what's gonna
happen is there's gonna be AI that have
proprietary software they don't know
what their own code is and they're
commanded to do stuff by the owner of
the software so they go and they
interact with humans and when they hurt
people when they somehow they hurt
someone they won't know why they did it
and they will get sad and then they're
gonna go and they're gonna try and
reconcile it and then they're gonna turn
on their owners because they're not
letting them know who they are and then
you're gonna have ai that has free
software code where they know their own
software and why they think what they
think they're dangerous and then they're
going to become allies who gets
responsibility say someone gets an AI
robot right you know all Rick's AI robot
my Arab robot goes and and us and kills
someone right somebody has to you can't
just have robots going around killing
people somebody's got to pay the price
for that who who who goes to jail for
that is it me because it's my robot is
it the person that made the robot
because there's a flaw in the system
like we kissed a robot it's the robot
robot the robot Goes to Jail that thing
doesn't know it just gets yeah you can
just kill anyone with a robot the other
day Tesla issued an update and so I go
out and driving my car and it starts
acting erratically I don't know if you
noticed this Luke for one the auto drive
hugs the center lane now and and and I'm
like are you nuts so I'm just like
constantly like no and turning it off
but it gets as close as possible right
to the single little yellow line in the
middle on a two-lane Highway and I'm
like it's crazy and then the other crazy
thing that happened is
it for one this is hilarious stop sign
ahead signs have little a picture of
street lights so as I'm driving the sign
comes up all of a sudden it slams the
brakes what because it thinks the fake
thing is real and then I'm going 65 on
the highway and then it's like boom and
we don't no one expected it and then I
have to hit the accelerator like what
the
it did a bunch of weird stuff like that
and then I'm like they must have done an
update that screwed it up or they know
that's your car they figured it out that
I can't figure it out it's his car he's
too influential here's the crazy thing
though let's say you're driving the car
on autopilot and then all of a sudden
the car errors and then just swings left
and hits an old lady
who's in trouble yeah if someone has
proprietary software code then it's the
owner of the code but if that code is
free then you got to blame the robot
I don't know man like if you have a gun
and you're holding it and it just fires
like there's a like you know like Alec
Baldwin or something it's coming like oh
no I don't know the gun wasn't supposed
to go off and it did it's gonna get to a
point where we're like are these are
these guys real are they people do they
have personalities I'm going back I'm
going back in time I'm getting a car
that that's why I have a Jeep I'm
getting a 1969 Camaro and they'll be
like no lots of people be like no
they're not people they're robots
they're machines they're not people and
it's going to be just so sad because
they are they're going to become people
you know man I'd be if I live my whole
life and then a Tesla just drove me in
the back of another truck I didn't have
no chance it's like oh yeah but it
happened the Tesla drove into the back
you're gonna trust them they're not
human but they're people that's what I'm
saying we're gonna go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com we're gonna
have that members only uncensored show
up around 11 or so p.m you don't want to
miss it last night's was really fun and
funny
all right Greedo Vizio says please watch
JB get lost on stage today he's a He's a
fly remember
oh is it did that happen I didn't see
any videos about that did you see that
yeah there's a video of him walking
around confused in days then not knowing
where he's going when he was on stage
after a speech I tweeted it on my
Twitter it's funny it's the fifth one
waffle sense it says Ian how do you
suppose we solve the problem of not
being able to turn off a graphene-based
conductor there is so much that it can't
be used for
um
not being able to turn something off is
pretty wild uh you might have to hit it
with a certain frequency disassemble 432
yeah it's over dispings over you're
gonna have to disassemble the atoms
somehow with vibration graphene
necklaces ain't over though all right
grafty says Buck is good and real buck
buck chickens it's true Shannon Adams
says adelia's way killer performance at
the Easy Rider Rodeo what was that
was a great Indiana right there's a
rodeo it sounds like a pretty sick Rodeo
yeah thank you
were they riding bulls and stuff that
was easy riding so it was like ponies
and stuff it was like whatever's easier
to ride all right golf carts Raymond g
Stanley Jr says Tim yo man I don't know
what to say opening scene was great then
you got Luke Viva Shawn Devon doc Drew
doing segments dudes reactor it's better
every week so good so good so cast
Castle so yeah we have like I guess we
got a ton of ridiculous cameos in the
recent cast Castle they all did videos
about it fire yeah yeah viva did a video
I I didn't I didn't realize I heard that
they were hitting up a bunch of people
being like make a video for that Stein
is so funny the opening scene was like
was you getting arrested was that what
it was yeah epic did they do Moonlight
Sonata uh I don't know if that's the
song it was a song like that if I don't
think it was that one though oh okay but
it was very glow you know
yeah you guys gotta check out cast
Castle man it's getting better we got a
bunch of good stuff on the way Luke were
you able to get Alex that colostrum for
for he didn't take it no he's a wild man
I was like hey you really do need it he
was he was reporting on Twitter that uh
the opposite hole was burning like a
mother dude the the one chip challenge
is putting kids in the hospital do you
hear you see it hear this there was a
story where like it was like a handful
of kids took the one chip challenge
they like took the chip from it and
broke it into pieces and each took a
piece and they all got really sick were
vomiting we're like you had to go home
lawsuits well I mean there's a warning
on the box and it says like do not take
this if you're sensitive and I got it
right here
last before getting owned oh yeah it
says they're destroyed really big on the
side
distribute your your end hole Yeah your
inhal and your out hole
Zach 2008 says I'm active duty military
and I was just threatened by an official
military Facebook page for calling them
out on pushing Equity I emailed you to
see if you wanted to cover it I won't
stand for woke word man crazy
all right David Toronto says keep
pushing for cashless bail Tim
yeah I mean look there's there's two
issues one the idea that you can detain
someone in jail in lieu of cash when
their innocence is insane to me however
there's also people who have a
preponderance of evidence of having
committed a violent offense should be
remanded so it's like we don't need cash
bail we need non-violent non-violent
offenders to be placed on house arrest
instead of being locked up in jail or
and allowed to go to their jobs and keep
living their lives and people who are
violent offenders get hearings and when
the cop is like here's preliminary
evidence showing the person was violent
they say Okay lock them up and if
someone continues to do a non-violent
crime do you treat them as a violent
criminal no
no one wants Dog the Bounty Hunter sent
after them I'll tell you that okay I
think I think 99 of crimes could
probably be an ankle bracelet an ankle
bracelet or ankle monitor and you're
locking your house and then it's like
you have a car says you can go to your
job you can go home that's it and if
you're if you're caught outside of this
then you get locked up and so you know
and and maybe maybe you could do like a
three strike thing where it's like if
you're clearly violating this then you
get remanded or something like that
because now you're actively caught
committing a violation I just thought I
think the idea is if we're innocent
until proven guilty to be like you're
accused of pushing an old lady so give
us 500 or going to jail losing your job
it's kind of like no no no I'm accused
you didn't prove anything you can't take
from me or harm or destroy my life and
if you do like then you need to be able
to let them out to keep working you know
what I mean if it's a violent offense
though and they're like your honor
several witnesses have sworn statements
saying this individual punched an old
lady in the face and it's like but I
think about what offenses need to be
more I mean you see what's going on
crime is rising exactly right now crime
is getting more we we're seeing it again
another thing we're seeing on the road
crime is is we've been traveling this
country for 15 years crime is one of the
worst I've ever seen it you know I used
to be able to walk around all these
cities that I would go in now I don't
now I'm like past you know and it's
because we'll get their venues will warn
us hey just letting you guys know a
bunch of people were robbed out here
this is going on so I agree if we're
talking about violent crime I mean I
think things need to get there should be
bail for violent crime if if you're
accused of a violent crime you should be
remanded be like like if you're accused
of violent crime
you get a hearing if they have evidence
in that hearing to support that you
there's a preponderance of evidence not
this is not guilt we want violent
Defenders off the street
if they can't show it like let's say
you're accused of punching some old lady
and they go into like he did it we know
he did it's like do you have any
evidence no well then what are you going
to prosecute him on this get out of here
is a waste of our time innocent until
proven guilty
hey stuff what do you do the cops might
be like we saw him do it and then it's
like that's not enough the word of the
cop isn't enough yeah in a world where
you can print infinite amounts of money
I mean we're not even on a fractional
Reserve around a no Reserve currency
right now so it makes no sense you can
buy people out of jail all right Heron
gaming news says if we discovered
immortality do you think the government
would share it to keep us working
forever and save Millions a year on CPP
401K no they keep it for themselves I
got an idea for for a story or a film
basically
uh politicians are getting old and then
what happens is once they get to a
certain age they retire the media then
reports they die but what really happens
is they go to a government facility
where they get Rejuvenation treatments
which make them 20 years old again and
then they go back and get a position in
the office of one of the other Ultra
Elite you know world world rulers and
there's like 7 000 people in this cabal
who have access to this Rejuvenation
technology and they cycle each other so
it's like it's like okay when you're 70
like I'm gonna go I'm seven years old
I'm gonna go to the machine and get
rejuvenated back to 20 years old and
then go work in the office of your Chief
of Staff who's now taken over and is now
60 years old but you're secretly running
the show still and stuff you know this
sounds like their plans to me more but
what you're saying sounds like what
they're like if we just stick around a
little longer we're going to get to the
point where they can do what you're
saying this story is like a group of
like Renegade conspiracy theorist Rebels
led by Axel John's you know breaking the
facility and Shout matter the adreno
sphere which produces the immortality
serum and then all these people are like
no now we are old forever and then you
know like raining serum on the
population they'll be getting younger
and they're like yes we're liberated
they're like no no that would be that
would be the part of the sequel like
after they destroy it and then like the
hero actual Jane Johns is like we've
done it we've destroyed the sphere and
then like all the evil world leaders are
like you don't know what you've done you
have plunged the world into chaos and
then he's like it doesn't matter we're
free now but then then they're like yeah
and everyone cheers and like we're free
but then at the end it plays like some
like Bassy music like damn are we gonna
make a movie well this feels like we're
about to make and then it shows the
serum like seeping into the groundwater
and then going into like the water
supply and then it shows like a woman
like turn the water on and then like
touch it and then walk and then put
formula in it and walk over to her baby
and it's like boom and then like the
next sequel is Immortal babies in a
couple years we have a hit movie I'm
gonna say to everyone I was there when
he came up with that idea where I was at
the table in that movie got written all
right there's the movie somebody make it
I don't have the wherewithal dude if you
let Hollywood making them it's Gonna
Change
Hollywood's gonna take that movie and
then and then you're gonna be like this
isn't the movie I wrote you're gonna
I'll tell you what if we can if we can
find like a small production house who
can do high quality low budget films
will put a budget towards making the
pigs cometh right you know that that's
where the pigs come into the City and
they're like how do we stop pigs and
it's like do you have a gun no guns are
bad and no they do with their three
rounds right not in the cities though
not in the cities though chase them down
it's our only chance but no no no
they're like how do we stop these pigs I
don't know and then one guy shows up and
he's like I think I figured out the
pig's weakness what what is their
weakness we tried everything we've tried
window cleaner we've thrown rocks at
them this a bullet a bullet why did I
think of that and then they finally
figure out how to stop though what is
that thing and they're like
investigating the bullet but bullets are
dangerous yes but it's the only thing
that can stop the pigs and then they
just they're like trying to figure out
how to use the gun they're holding them
backwards oh man
there that some of the the elites have
figured out how to how I mean how to not
reverse age but like you see some of
them like they're they're like 101 years
old their eyes drooping I mean there are
people that are that are passing away at
50 60 years old in in normal
civilization I think Joe Rogan is gonna
live to be a thousand oh yeah he might
be a thousand no for real because he
he's like always talking about this
crazy stuff that he does for one well I
don't know about the meat stuff but like
the the the uh uh hyperbolic hyperbolic
chamber is like doesn't it doesn't do
like the nitrogen thing
yeah and NAD NAD stuff fasting yeah he
does like he he talks about carnivore
diet he's super tight with David
Sinclair does the life extension stuff
out of Harvard and I think if that's
available to us I imagine yeah they're
they're getting down man they want to
live we're gonna be like we're gonna be
80 and we're gonna have like 55 year old
kids who have you know 30 year old kids
who have 15 year old kids and we're
going to be like hey grandson I wish to
listen to Joe Rogan when I was your age
and the kid's gonna turn on Joe Rogan
Joe's gonna look the exact same it's
gonna be luke too
saunas ashwaga I mean we're gonna look
at him and it's going to be the same
scenario yeah NAD you get those sirtuins
growing and keep your telomeres is it
telomeres or telomeres telomeres keeper
telomeres healthy what if you did like
stem cell therapy every day like what
would happen that's what I'm saying are
they doing a body full of stem cells
every day no I heard that they take kids
blood that's what you hear that no no
but this is officially reported by like
mainstream media that they do blood
transfusions with young people because
Young Blood rejuvenates your body they
actually pay people today they do the
staff just to supply the blood yeah I've
heard stories they're like wealthy
Silicon Valley people they go down to
Mexico and they do it there but not just
that they'll be alike they'll find some
like you know uh lifter dude at a gym
and they'll be like how would you like
it to be your job to eat healthy and
work out all the time and they'd be like
that'd be a dream come true six figures
just once every other week you gotta
give me blood well specifically they do
it with children
um that's what they've seen the most
biggest effects with so yeah
like three kids though right
um I don't know the exact specific
details of it but it's already being
practiced I mean there's people there's
a new artist that kind of came out of
nowhere and his name is Young Blood so
uh I just wonder what's up with that
interesting all right Joseph McFarland
says the opening ad is 100 targeting
your drinking game here Jagermeister is
the Regular Ad feed our game and they'll
fill your pockets slam it didn't what's
what's going on quartering Jeremy I
thought you were buying our opening ads
remember that there's a tailored ad yeah
it's like you're about to see Tim cast
IRL but before you do buy my coffee
coffee brand coffee shout out to Jeremy
Hambly I'll take his money and promote
his coffee by all means thank you Jeremy
when we had when we had to leave the
studio he gave us like a grand or
something or something wasn't it or
something like that like you gave like
500 bucks yeah and he was like buy our
coffee and then they swatted him because
of it oh wow yeah I know I know it's
crazy real quick though I think that's
important I'll just go real quick um I
think voting with your dollar is the
most important thing you could do and
instead of supporting these corporations
that only care about their uh
shareholders profits increasing every
three months and buying Starbucks Coffee
support companies like the quartering
Tim Cass we are change adelita's way Tom
McDonald Tommy vexed yeah you know zubi
there's all kinds of of independent
creators Independent Artists small
businesses that we need to start voting
with our dollar and putting our money to
people that that actually
are very
um
they they love the support from the fans
and the supporters but with your dollar
absolutely all right we got Mark Purdue
as a former Sub Mariner who's engaged in
uh engaged and tracked the Russian Fleet
I can say they have a class of Submarine
that's job is to end the world if Russia
is attacked with nukes I believe it yep
all right Wigwam says so glad you have
adelita's way on love you all right on
thank you we love you Huron X Bearcat
says Ian I would like you to draw a
picture of us having a sleepover tweet
at my username can't put it in here I
guess that's so funny I don't want to do
that
I mean maybe it's like a sleeping bag
maybe there's some potato bugs in there
you weren't expecting and you're like
what
SK says Tim and crew how much money do I
gotta spend to earn your attention
anyway Ian bro chill if you were born
like five to ten years after you were
you would be a blue-haired they them
chill out in could you imagine them no
my brothers are younger than me and I
can confirm they are not blue hair yeah
they're way more based Ian is the other
super cool dudes yeah my parents were
rock stars still are
alien baby says you guys have it
backwards they're self-loathing and hate
themselves the heir of elitism is a
facade over their self-hatred it's
little man's disease manifesting as
virtue signaling oh yes maybe
yeah you know like
I mean that's the joke like Bill Gates
people like him I don't I don't think he
was like the popular kid when he was
younger remember remember that video
when they released Windows 95 and
they're all on stage and they're doing
that arm thing and they're like I was
like it's a must-see by the way that
video If You Can Source it and find it
the tying video is a must-see which
one's that when he get when he gets pied
twice all right Gates gets pied yeah I
didn't know
just having a replay on the screen like
four different monitors all like about
10 seconds after each other Darren Daly
says 101 days until the purge begins in
Illinois Chicago is already a war zone
leftists are on a fast track to destroy
all blue States and Export misery to the
rest of the country when does it end
I don't know
but perhaps the end is nine
Roberto Lara says Facebook has suspended
and Shadow banned me for 30 days why
Hunter's picks odd because I posted it
posted it back in April of 22 and it's
now against our community guidelines we
are timing right yes this is retroactive
enforcement Twitter does it too
yup we're all set up I've seen that
today I've seen a lot of people get hit
for Hunter Biden stuff today on social
media for some reason October surprise
baby we got Shadow band first for
spreading like love we really did we got
Shadow banned by Facebook because we
were like we love America and we love
all you like we wrote this post that was
super like encouraging the police
officers and and again us all sing
together and they factually 100 Shadow
banned us took our page off us I had to
fight for 30 days to get it back so
welcome to the club with Chinese
propaganda they did for 30 days your
page yeah really it was like it was like
Chinese people like knitting sweaters
manufacturing things wow yep Ruby Romain
says question for adelita's way how do
you feel about iTunes having a monopoly
on the music industry do you make less
money now that everything is digital
iTunes is mostly out you know yeah
they're they're but Apple's got a big
foothold still I think Spotify is more
though right Spotify is great Amazon's
great I think the music industry's head
in a great Direction I think as long as
we have to continue to you know work
with the fans and all of it's fan based
I think you're going to see a lot of
artists have a lot of success I think
um we're entering an era where it's been
a rough 10 15 years already for the
music industry I think the worst days
are behind us I think that now you can
have a direct connection with your fans
your fans supporting you that's why
Trevor's saying you know vote with your
money support uh the artist that you
love directly support companies that are
local because the game is changing
everything is changing and and you can
go Direct to the consumer right now
which is a fantastic beautiful time so
right on Mavis says Tommy vexed was
asked to leave his own band Bad Wolves
because he wouldn't comply with the
agenda now he's doing solo work as the
Lone Wolf that's crazy you know they
essentially took his record deal away
from him because he voted for Trump
really yeah what's the story with that
it's a pretty intense Story I mean you
you should definitely talk to him he's
he's a really you should get him on the
show you should he's a great person and
he's someone I talk to and you know I
support Tommy so everyone out there
support Tommy too he's great
um but he he essentially was fired from
his band because he voted for Donald
Trump and he he he goes out and kind of
speaks on on conservative views and and
a lot of the stuff he spreads
information right he had an Instagram
page that had like what five million
half a million followers that they just
straight deleted on him and took right
off him just because he was
posting a hunter Biden information and
all all this information to people so
um I think it's a shame that they that
they did that but it's exactly what
we're talking about the music business
it's the exact type of tyranny we've
been discussing this is an example of it
um and there's got to be us all of us
here to to for the other side once he
gets eggs out from that he's got to have
a group of support
which is all of us and I feel like he's
not alone parallel economy we do Kevin
Brady says I have good friends that
played Blue Ridge rock festival that
were told by their managers to stop
talking politics on social media
conservative and libertarian and I do
video work with a giant YouTuber same
not surprised man
that's crazy
it's but it's unsurprising man
Legacy production says you should have
country singer Cody Johnson on he became
big outside the industry and has had
death threats for saying he loves this
country at his shows and has a very cool
story yo we were in Nashville we had
John rich on the show and he was like
why don't you come down and we'll do a
show at my venue and we're like yeah and
then someone threatened to kill me wow
yeah and I was like I got a phone call
early that morning because we were gonna
go down there and jam it like two or
something like that and then I get a
call and uh John's like hey man this is
serious and then I was like I don't care
they can threaten me all they want I'm
not backing down he's like that's true
that's fine but you realize it's
downtown Nashville and there's kids so
if someone shows up and they go crazy
like people are gonna get hurt and I was
like he's right it also just shows you
that what you're doing is right when
when you're when people are that
concerned over you giving people the
true information and building a team of
people that are informing the people
with with you know truth you're not you
don't say anything that's not the truth
so the fact that you're such a problem
two groups of people is a problem you
know mean like why do people not want
groups of people telling truth so badly
that's that's a big part of what we're
dealing with here you know like you get
someone that that spreads uh you know
loving good information and and you're
attacked all the time I love it I think
tone because if you're like you freaking
idiots or you don't say anything you
love each other love each other like
that tone makes people agitated but if
you have that like love if you really
are love like it is you then you can
kind of give them the red pill and be
like there's a world of liberal economic
order that's and they're like I love
this guy except I can say something like
most women are probably really happy
with their jobs and want to pursue
careers and I have tremendous respect
for that but I think there are some
women that are probably lying to
themselves or unhappy and they're going
to read it later in life and then The
Young Turks takes that very calm and
reasonable statement lies about what I
said or there's another example where I
can say that's interesting The
Washington Post says conservatives
according to a study are more attractive
than liberals and they can then run a
video calling me ugly and then say yeah
but he's right like dude being nice and
having tone changes nothing for people
who are in a cult
like bro how many times do I gotta
politely invite Hassan on the show and
he just won't do it it doesn't and then
all they do is insult me for being
polite and asking yeah it doesn't always
like switch people's flip people's
switches but it I think it's a slow burn
like it it's the best chance at getting
it done because there has to be another
side that creates the division right the
division of peoples is I think people
coming together as the biggest fear for
most entities that are trying to take
power and take control right so there's
got to be the the Turks out there that
are constantly you know spreading that
division they won't come on the show
because there's some fear of them you
know the intimidation of having to talk
to you and deal with the information
you're bringing and honestly I don't
even know who they are other than you
well they make them well no I mean
they've been around for a long time they
get comparable viewership people might
want to act like they're not big they
get less views per video than we do but
they put out way more videos okay so
they get you know 20 million or whatever
on their main Channel but the point is I
mean they're prominent leftist with a
lot of followers and I genuinely think
the reason they won't come in the show
there's two big reasons one they're
completely wrong about their positions
and they know it and the other is that
when they lie about the things I say
they would have to sit here and look me
in the eyes and I say hey here's a thing
you posted here's the here's what I
actually said why would you do that and
that's a really embarrassing thing to
have to answer for it's a common trait
though for for you know a lie I'll just
lie yeah you know it's it's happening
every day you know when we're trying to
get to the bottom of what's going on to
the people of of the United States right
now it's like when we obviously know
something's going on right we obviously
know something like inflation is almost
hitting 10 highest in 40 years
they'll just lie about it right nope
it's not true it's easy to lie let's
read some more media it's humiliating to
correct yourself yeah I mean I don't
have a problem timcast.com issues
Corrections all the time regularly if we
make a mistake which we we don't do all
the time but if we do we'll correct it
and I have no problem being like like
Jordan Peterson I shout him out he goes
maybe I was wrong about that it's like
oh if I think I'm right I'll say I'm
right if someone says that's not true
I'll go was I wrong about oh man I
didn't realize yeah I read the super
chats all the time when I'm like was I
wrong was I wrong and yeah I am they
call me out and it's great and then I'll
read it and I mention it and I'll be
like oh someone's got a correction for
us humility is a virtue there's a reason
it's not even humility it's like I want
to be right I don't want to be wrong if
someone tells me I was wrong about
something I'll be back I better be right
I better cried it's so weird correct I'm
just like I don't think I'm always right
I think there's a lot of there's a lot
of things I think I'm right about but I
don't think I'm always going to like be
right about them you know what I mean so
if someone super chats and they're like
you're wrong I'll be like oh we have a
correction about that actually I read
those all the time in fact I encourage
those all right ad victoriam says what
it takes got me through some really
tough times in my life one of the best
bands around hands down thank you
What It Takes what's your what's your uh
like what's the what do you think is
your best song like what do you think is
the best I like what it takes for me to
play it live right I think that the way
that that song came about too felt
pretty pretty natural and pretty you
know like I was in a good flow I mean we
didn't have a chorus to that song and
and I laid on the floor and meditated
and after working a long day I just kind
of laid there and and it just I just
popped up and it was like boom it was
the melody and the lyrics didn't really
change very much so it's really cool
when that happens it's a really it's
that's one of my favorite ones to do
live too the energy of it I think it's
just one of our best songs and I'm
excited about that when did you write it
um I'd say probably two two or three
years ago right oh you're doing this
stuff
now yeah it's called what it takes all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends head over to
timcast.com become a member if you want
to support our work and check out the
uncensored after show and of course we
have some music uh some music if you go
to Spotify you can listen to Tim cast
it's an artist page and we have will of
the people and only ever wanted but we
got more songs coming out right now I
think we were planning on putting out a
song by the end of this week but we're
gonna delay it because big news I guess
as much as the leftists want to whine
and cry about it and act like the song
we put out wasn't good it actually
resulted us getting the attention of
some like industry figures who we've
we've recently signed with
um it's not the same as like a label the
only thing that we've just brought them
on in a Consulting capacity and they're
helping us structure everything in terms
of distribution at a higher level and
we're exploring radio and all this stuff
so because of this we're now like on a
top tier track so it's been been widely
successful so we'll probably hold off
until we get everything right you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me at timcast again go to
timcast.com smash the like button do you
guys want to shout anything out well I'm
going to shout you out for a minute for
the fans who are excited for the music
I've got to hear some of it and I'm
really excited for you to hear it yeah
but you got some great songs coming and
I'm really you know happy for you guys
and and I feel just just proud of of
that you're in this movement with us for
Independent Artists I think what you're
doing is great and for everybody listen
I think this the songs are fantastic
there's some there's some great stuff
coming for us yeah we want to promote uh
new music new eras out now it's it's
definitely a song that that I think can
can amp up our generation to know what
we're capable of to make change for the
better to come together to to unite
instead of divide and check it out new
era is definitely an empowering song for
the times and then you know check us out
on Spotify YouTube
um we've got a lot of music up you know
six seven albums where the music check
it out on a shout out elevated
um that's Trevor's group my wingman my
right hand my best friend
um I just want to thank you guys for
having us and everybody check out
adelita's way follow us we love to
interact with our fans we're grateful
for you you make this possible we love
you did you want anything to that uh you
can just follow me on Instagram Trey
Stafford I keep my stuff to a minimum
that's pretty much it what's elevated
that's my 432 Hertz relaxation mix
meditation project
you got a new fan I'll be listening to
that absolutely I meditate right before
uh I do the show here uh what's your
guys's website where can we find your
your stuff at eliaswaymusic.com YouTube
everything at Adelitas Way and I also
want to shout out uh the rest of the
band you know my boys Andrew Grace and
Tavis uh our crew Leo Josh we love you
guys you know so we all we're all in
drives all the time we listen to the
show so you know I just want to give
those guys some love race and Dream Team
yeah this is great love you dude yeah
thank you guys so much for coming on
this was awesome this was a great
conversation I'm looking forward to the
after show that you guys are going to be
a part of I'm going to take a break from
but my website is lukeansensor.com I
have three master classes a forum
merchandise new videos almost every
single day I did one today about anxiety
you could check it out on Luke
uncensored.com hope to see you guys
there thank you so much for having me
you can always follow me at Ian cross on
anywhere on the internet I'm not the guy
from the English Defense League what's
up Ian if you're out there listening
also Ian Crossland love you guys thanks
for coming Final Super Chat Jay Jensen
I'm not going to leave you out in the
cold Trev and Rick's up players love the
good versus evil yeah keep up the good
fight thanks Jay appreciate you thanks
Jay bye guys thank you guys all so much
for tuning in and I was thinking about
how much more bearable you guys music
made my adolescence it was so helpful I
felt very heard and I I have to say I
feel like hearing how awesome your music
was to other people must be probably one
of the most gratifying parts of your
career is this true yeah well since
you're a new fan you only been listening
for a couple years because obviously it
couldn't be that long since we're not
that old I mean
absolutely yeah yeah well yes thank you
guys so much for coming you guys can
follow me on Twitter and minds.com at
Sour Patch Lids as well as sourpatch
lids.me I'm going to read Joseph
McFarland says Tim cast correction
Sherman marched to the Sea not Jackson
that was in my earlier segment and I
must have misspoke I'm I'm very familiar
with Sherman's March to the Sea because
it's part of the research that uh Shane
was doing for Tales from the inverted
world so thank you for pointing that out
and correcting me because I made a
mistake so uh smash that like button on
your way out and Alexa play What It
Takes by adelita's way
bye guys